peu
[Musique]
vanille
[Applaudissements]
alors hier
bon bon bon en bas
venu sur le plateau de tout le monde en
parle l'émission dont tout le monde
parle avec nous ce soir
laurent baffie
enrico macias
[Musique]
ok
le photographe accusé de proxénétisme
elsa zylberstein il a infiltré al-qaïda
en france
[Musique]
natacha amal
michel edouard leclerc
chaque nom
tu oublies pas
révélations sur la famille bush
la plus sexy des sopranos à
et notre peuple à une thèse consacrée ce
soir mais c'est oblige au brésil
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
mais avant de recevoir notre première
invitée je vous propose de regarder les
meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde va parler et
s'est préparé par monsieur georges noël
nieto serge je n'avais pas été considéré
comme un citoyen non non non c'était
plus c'est plus algérien que français
oui on en quinze jours vous avez connu
beaucoup de musiciens notamment ulf
wilex l'ex tous les films que vous
faites avec mcb sont là vous devez
reconnaître de la star vous ah oui
beaucoup de bons skis aux lf experts
glenn beck
non quand vous étiez même qu'à vous
marchiez plus vite ou moins vite que
claudia schiffer beaucoup plus vite et
mieux
dites moi madame vous avez déjà fait
l'amour dans un taxi ah oui puis ces
phrases salée pour les chauffeurs
on voulait pas si nous avons attrapé la
loupe
non si on est désolé il peut pas
m'embrasser sur la bouche parce qu'il
est académicien
enfin je peux vous remplacer alors le
pitch finalement c'est votre vie le
pitch le fameux il faut de l académie ce
mot je compte sur vous pour que le mot
pitt se rendent dans le dictionnaire la
langue française alors je n'ai pas
encore fait entre à l'académie je les
fais entrer chez gallimard et je leur ai
dit je vais vous expliquer le pic je
pique et personne chez gallimard vous
savez ce que voulait bien le faire alors
j'ai dit mais comment vous n'écoutez pas
ardisson mieux encore alors si c'était à
refaire
si c'était à refaire je ne le referais
pas 1 non franchement
évidemment si bon pour conjurer le sort
on va passer à votre oraison funèbre est
patent voici dieudonné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est très mince est ce que c'est parce
que votre cuisine et pas très bonne
non c'est parce que parce que voilà ce
que répondait qu'il aille se faire
[ __ ]
la recette pour avoir votre numéro de
portable mais c'est pas moins de la
donner pour une fois la recette là ouais
maintenant faut faire preuve d'un peu
d'imagination ouais comme on peut le
trouver ses marques cuisine et je vous
dis on m'a tellement fait souffrir là
que je crois que je vais le mettre aux
enchères votre numéro de la femme avec
qui vous n'auriez pas aimé coucher
stevie du loft même debout jean marais
suppliant les grosses conneries
sem
je suis assez ému que la gagnerie çi
soit présent que j'avais en face de moi
quand même parce que c'est you say me
pour moi c'est une chanson occulter une
belle chanson d'amour puisque c'est
pendant ces ihu semic j'ai connu mon
premier fils fucking réellement cause
dans le monde je peux y a des enfants
qui meurent de faim il reste que 6000
rené au ciro's quelques milliers de
tigre géant ont tué des gens ici à
droite et à gauche tout ce que vous
venez dire c'est oui il faut que les
révisionnistes où il faut que les
racistes puisse s'exprimer
je m'en balance l'elysée raciste et a
exprimé sa recrue s'est passé à bordeaux
ont nagé pas vraiment besoin de vos
leçons pour défendre la liberté ailleurs
et pas seulement dans des salons pour
casser la gueule moi j'ai reçu des bons
mois j'étais ici moi j'ai été là quels
sont vos faits vous gérez salle pas miss
imerys berry midnapore y en a pas venant
de vous faites quoi rigoler ce que je
vous somme qui tu es
c'est le même score de la semaine passée
ça s'appelle tout le monde
c'est bête hein
j'aurai une rave
et maintenant
merci laurent davezies
oh
alors
non
la peau
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter commença
alors très bien
bon alors la tournée de la pièce sexe
magouille et culture générale
c'est où en ce moment un petit peu
partout en france en belgique puisque
j'arrive à l'instant de belgique on a
fait une super représentation au grand
théâtre du palais royal du roi de la
belgique je ne sais plus quoi ma faim c
sipa bien passé le roi était vantant le
roi était très content il a participé
c'est pas le dernier pour la déconne
c'était très sympa que c'est bien les
rois oui c'est bien c'est bien dans ce
contexte là c'est bien et à part ça il
ya quoi qui est prévu comme colville ah
je sais pas je les ai pas apprise par
coeur puis on m'a dit tu te fais pas
chier avec la promo s'est plaint assez
plein à la bravo dix ans
comment tableau alors on s'est pas vue
pendant quelques mois laurent parce
qu'elle est ce film we en tournage alors
ça en est où j'ai tourné 90% du film à
peu près et puis moi des choses à
tourner et puis ce qu'on appelle la
postproduction qu'il faut organiser en
même temps qu'une tournée qu une pièce
tout ça est très compliqué je suis un
petit peu trop de choses et parfois ça
se voit quoi mais enfin bon j'en suis
plutôt content je crois que c'est un
sujet formidable ça s'appelle comment
s'appellent les clefs de bagnole en gros
l'histoire c'est que j'ai paumé métier
de bagnols et je pensais que ça méritait
bien un film
g
j'accueille maintenant enrico macias
fabre
salut l'instant
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment un court très bien c'est
un accueil comme ça bah ouais comme chez
hbo à rien de s'énerver enrico vous
savez remettez la sourde il pas hélas
tout cas ses fils et bien fini pour moi
[Applaudissements]
alors elle même qu il ya un loup qu'elle
sera ordinaire là c'est vachement bien
en forme main c'est tout
[Musique]
l hélico macias mesdames messieurs 64
ans enrico when i'm sixty fort 40 ans de
carrière
quarante ans de mariage on va commencer
par la carrière didier j'ai quitté une
amie je voulais en français
enfants de tous
[Musique]
la famille
son joli demandé
bayonne
leïla
jallet
le long délai
roma
j'étais seul
j'avais pour
oap année
tu m'as fait nantais veut la garder
j
maison
besson
[Musique]
bon
les gens du nord en dans les îles eux
qui manque à leur décor
les gens du nord
en vain
soleil
qui n'ont pas dehors
de la ville on m'appelle m
moi je
écoutez coup de main droite
écoutons
il
[Musique]
pourtant la souris
et un point
avec le coeur qui tendent
je revois des
le chemin fut long
hello there
soro
et l'odeur des
très tôt vachement bien bilodeau
jean
nous
et comme un cias non
elle est comme un cias et les deux
guerres
la chanson convient
l'entente sont extraits du nouvel album
d'abricots macias qui s'appelle orge
amer
[Musique]
avec le coeur qui tambourine à l'égard
je revois
de molly
le chemin
pauli et l'odeur les oranje amiens et le
danger n'est seulement que jamais
bravo à l'alcool est très bonne ce sera
sans moi c'est la même chanson féliciter
et féliciter marc est un berlingot voilà
très très bonne chanson rue l'autre
qu'on a entendu écoute ma voix c'est
kent
voilà alors enrico depuis quelques
années il ya eu l'album hommage consacré
à la musique de cheikh raymond la
musique arabo andalouse le malouf et us
a ensuite il ya eu un remix de tous vos
grands tubes par bill laswell et là
maintenant avec ce nouveau disque on a
le sentiment d'assister vraiment à un
renouveau à une renaissance d'enrico
macias
je dirais ça un peu comme avec henri
salvador il ya quelques il ya quelques
temps qu'on souhaite faire le même
succès que wayne salvador ray mais je
dois tout à mon fils qui m'a qui a
réalisé totalement le disque qui m'a
présenté ses nouveaux auteurs ces
nouveaux compositeurs et qui a décidé de
je me suis mis carrément entre ses mains
pour soigner pendant sept ans j'ai j'ai
senti qu'il fallait que je prenne un peu
de recul qu'il fallait même nourrir
sentir ne commence pas toi
bon
et alors c'est vrai que ça fait c'est
andry cauwet s'étant les années passées
un ouais alors pourquoi pas de chansons
nouvelles pendant ce temps peur de ne
pas arriver à faire des choses qui soit
au niveau des des tubes d'enrico moi
j'ai jamais calculé pour faire des
chansons et quand ça venait pas
ben ça venait pas oui je ne pouvais pas
forcé je peux pas forcément sur des
bases solides pour faire des suites par
exemple les gens du sud et ouest nantes
a pas eu pourtant tu vois tu vois c'est
pas mon style tu vois pour revenir très
fort comme ça j'ai pas besoin de faire
ça c'est jean-claude effectivement votre
si ce qui vous a convaincu abricots de
vous y remettre
il a réuni une équipe dont il ya marc
estève alors lui c'est quand même plus
facile parce que son père était
footballeur d'un design ans oui ouais on
a on s'est rappelé de certains souvenirs
je ne connais pas encore séparé ça va
c'est un rocker qui vit dans le sud
voilà et qu'il ya un mois l'a fait cette
chanson avec art mengo qui est son grand
copain d'eau qui a beaucoup de talent et
conseil vise nommément un c'est vraiment
très très belle chanson est alors quand
vous entendez ça orange amère
oui c'est j'entends orange amère et je
me dis là il ya quelque chose de que je
n'ai pas fait encore depuis 40 ans parce
que j'ai horreur de refaire la même
chanson est là pour la première fois de
ma vie j'entends quelque chose qui a qui
est dans mon style qui est dans mon
univers musical dans le moment
environnement et qui rappelle quand même
un grand génie qui rappelle je m'excuse
c'est peut-être grandiloquent mais c'est
pour moi marc estève
ouais c'est un petit peu camus mais dans
la chanson ouais ouais c'est le même
style les choses simples mais automne si
importante quand on se réveille le matin
on demande
il fait beau il fait mauvais il ya du
soleil ça paraît banal mais c'est
vachement important pour mes rêves donc
marc estève art mengo pour cette chanson
orange amère
et puis ensuite jean loup dabadie
georges moustaki et puis kent pour celle
là qui s'appelle écoute ma voix et
mais vous de ma voix
[Musique]
j'ai le pis pour toi
voici kent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
salut les bienvenus bienvenue quand à
moi j'étais fan de quinton et des
siècles c'était starshooter moi j'étais
un un malade de starshooter ensuite vous
avez chanté en solo jamin pays qui est
une très très belle chanson puis en duo
avec enzo et aujourd'hui donc il ya un
nouvel album qui s'appelle kent avec un
truc qui s'appelle je ne suis qu'une
chanson mais je suis une chance aux élus
si tu marais connu
je ne viens j'ai maté habiller nos murs
[Musique]
abandonnant mon corps change inédite
assure aux délires 1 2
de tendre à coder
inquiète je ne suis qu'une chanson
exposer son nouvel album qui s'appelle
tout simplement mesdames messieurs
alors ça me fait drôle en fait de très
très drôle de voir tous les deux à côté
parce que kent enrico macias si on
m'avait dit qu'un jour je vous verrai à
côté kent écrivant pour vous et maiko
j'aurais dit c'est pas possible
sérieux non mais quand vous étiez à lyon
en 77 est ce que vous pensez
sérieusement qu'un jour il y écrit des
chansons pour enrico macias
non non je pensais pas je pensais pas je
pensais pas parce que ça ne tenait pas
en tête
cela dit starshooter avec starshooter on
a collaboré avec korn agile aussi comme
truc c est donc tout est possible alors
un haricot la chanson la plus engagée
sans doute celle qui est signé par
dabadie qui s'appelle le voyage et qui
dit je ne l'ait pas fait ce voyage des
fous mon barré le passage aura
évidemment on voit bien de quel voyage
il s'agit c'est ce retour en algérie
si vous êtes parti en 62 vous est jamais
retourné et une fois quand même pour une
mission de l'onu vous avez survolé
constantine en avion c'est vrai on m'a
fait la surprise et pendant le voyage il
est passé au dessus de constantine il
mais c'est l'attitude quoi et puis j'ai
reconnu le paysage de constantine et
d'autour de quelques centimes j'ai bien
reconnu quoi c'était j'ai vu la vallée
du hamma j'ai vu le pont suspendu
c'est ça m'a fait quelque chose quoi
terrible terrible mais oussama un petit
peu consolé d'abord fait savoir un petit
peu on avait parlé ici de ce voyage
magnéto serge deviez aller chanter où
vous devez aller chanter que je vais
chanter voilà austin le 18 mars
et puis partout en algérie voilà alors à
constantine annaba par bonne pleine
scène ouais tizi ouzou et alger dont
constantine ses droits à polluer oran et
alger celle 27 donc si une tournée en
algérie et après on peut dire qu après
38 ans dont il ya 38 ans vous avez
quitté l'algérie s'est jamais retourné
et la boucler et en quelque sorte bouclé
si c'était quelque chose que je n'aurais
même pas imaginer en rêve
et puis qui viendra pas de m'arriver
comme un comme quelque chose c'est même
pas historique c'est messianique
ouais c'est mentionné peut-être c'est
beau une vie normale non a dit lui sa
valeur non non pas du tout ça
m'impressionne pas du tout je crois que
les jantes une fausse opinion de la
réalité des choses
je pense que tous les gens qui naissent
de rang devrait leur mettre un gilet
pare-balles aussi parce que à chaque
fois qu on est on est condamné à mort
mais toute façon ça bien mentalement à
le tout
quel déconneur à un cours alors vous y
allez en plus pendant la période de
l'aïd donc la fête du mouton qui la fête
du pardon dans la dans la région
musulmane et vous partez avec 200 autres
juifs d'algérie qui étaient là-bas à
l'époque et qui je pars avec 200 enfants
d'algérie de notre confession et nous
allons reconstruire un pont entre
l'algérie et la france
un pont qui a été un petit peu coupé
pendant longtemps pendant 40 ans
et puis voilà je suis fier d'être le
leader de cette merveilleuse histoire
cette nouvelle page de l'histoire que
j'ai chanté depuis 40 ans au moment où
vous en avez parlé ici vise à lier
partie à cet effet l'athlète s'était
vague était prête mais réalise était
prête et puis d'un coup grande polémique
née en algérie
comme je le dis dans la chanson qu'on
les a écrits loup jean loup dabadie mais
que je revendique aussi des fous mon
barré le passage bon c'est un point - je
ne dis pas ce qui va se passer dans
l'avenir
vaut mieux pas en tout cas mon cas
personnel n'a aucune importance par
rapport à ce que je souhaite en algérie
souhaitent que l'algérie devienne
pluriel je souhaite qu'elle soit une
véritable démocratie qu'elle retrouve la
paix civile et que tous les enfants
d'algérie soit reconnu et toutes les
cultures y compris les pieds noirs les
harkis les berbères les judéo arabe
enfin tous les enfants d'algérie et là
franchement ça sera la vraie fête ça
arrivera de toute façon même si c'est
pas de mon vivant c'est obligé que ça
arrive
[Applaudissements]
vous avez déclaré un héros en parlant de
l'annulation de ce voyage au dernier
moment à dernière minute soit disant
pour des raisons techniques
vous avez déclaré ça m'a plus c'est mal
quand 60 de oui parce que en 62 j'ai
subi l'histoire comme des mis des
millions de gens qui ont créé la même
histoire que moi et c'était une blessure
quand je voyais mes grands-parents être
déplacée comme ça nous les jeunes c'est
différent parce que on avait l'espoir
d'un nouveau monde c'était l'amérique
pour nous la france mais mais cette fois
ci la cicatrice qui commençait à se
refermer avec cette grande espérance de
retrouver cette réconciliation de tous
les enfants d'algérie qui ne s'est pas
fait
là ça m'a fait mal ça m'a fait mal et
encore une fois je vous répète c'est
c'est pas grave ce qui m'est arrivé à
moi personnellement un jour je ferai
abstraction de ma fierté personnelle
si c'est pour réussir cette grande
espérance
merci à la mairie qu'on vous demandait
de me faire un cadeau
mailing est ce qu'on peut apporter la
guitare de m
[Musique]
et voilà qu est-ce qu elie merci méline
enrico esprit juste me faire adieu mon
pays juste un petit bout de l'adieu mon
pays un petit bout en bout par imitation
[Musique]
j'ai quitté mon pays j'ai quitté ma mère
ma vie ma triste vie se traînent sans
raison
[Musique]
j'ai quitté mon soleil
j'ai quitté mes bleus leurs souvenirs se
révèle bien après mme la du soleil
seul de mon pays perdu des villes
blanches que j'aime
des filles que j'ai jadis connue mais du
bord du bateau qui nous éloignent
éduquer une chaîne dans l'eau a claqué
qu'on me fou et j'ai le temps
regardez
c'est je me kiffe lui et la mère les a
noyé dans le flot du regretté
en effet il ya quel sur la télé pour toi
[Applaudissements]
six mois
à
[Musique]
que j'aime
[Applaudissements]
ils autorités
quarante ans de carrière donc mis 4 l
olympia du 1er au 9 mars prochain
je passe avec quoi 17 18 fois fait
l'olympia ben oui j'ai jamais compte
exactement mais c'est ça fait oui je
crois mon simon 17e modem puis c'est ça
ouais là quarante ans de carrière 40 ans
de mariage dans la vous ferez pas parce
que suzy votre épouse a perdu sa mère il
ya pas longtemps hermance sa mère et
puis sa mère est décédée vraiment à la
suite du grand chagrin qu'elle a eue de
perdre s'applique il ya quelques mois
qui est la soeur de suzy on a passé très
très très dur mais enfin ça c'est la vie
de personnel de chacun sait c'est comme
ça et je salue le courage de suzy qui
est malgré cette épreuve saillie de
remonter le courant pot pour moi pour
les enfants pour le petit enfant et on
entoure de façon à ce que nous elle a un
courage ex exceptionnel exceptionnel
vous êtes combien quand vous vous
retrouvez là les mafias cela ça fait un
paquet dans quand il ya des massias les
amis alors maintenant enrico on va
remonter le temps on est en 63 il ya
quarante ans nous sommes au début de
votre carrière et je vous reçois sur
l'horaire tf
interview flash berre
[Musique]
henrie cause de décalage 64 ans je viens
d'avoir 60 il ya 40 ans enrico à 11 63
ans né en 63 fils oui je vais
recommencer
enrico je sais plus quel 24 jaricot 24
ans voilà 24 roman qui fait quand je
suis pas là enrico vous avez quel âge 24
ans bon alors ico votre carrière
commence à très bien marché mais est ce
que vous pensez que les durer comme ça
avec cette taxe en pieds noirs l'accent
pieds noirs sur wii mais durer comme ça
non je pourrais même pas vous avez vous
fait des efforts pour la paix à cet
accent même highco a je prends des cours
ouais je prends des cours pour le perdre
et vous pensez que dans quarante ans
vous l'aurais perdu mais j'ai déjà un
peu perdus si je veux alors mon pote ça
va être
[Applaudissements]
lime rock ça commence à marcher pour
vous est-ce que vous allez essayer la
guitare électrique
ah mais j'ai déjà essayé la guitare
électrique mon fils il m'a fait jouer de
la guitare électrique mais c'est un
régal jamais je ne jouais de la guitare
électrique jamais jamais d'après-vous
enrico d'ici quelques années
qu'est-ce qui va succéder au yéyé je
pense je pense que ça va être les
beatles à pense que ça mais bon c'est
une finale ça va marcher
ah oui les beatles moi j'ai écouté leur
premier disque là vraiment
extraordinaire cela s'est passé et j'ai
même appris que sylvie vartan elle est
passée avec les misères salle olympia à
bord avec traîner la jambe la chance à
lopez et moi les anglo saxons et
n'apprécie pas trop aidé géniale idée
vous l'appréciez ah oui j'apprécie
beaucoup
je suis passé au moulin rouge n'est pas
très longtemps mais il ya eu l'année
dernière 62 11 62 et werner je suis
passé avec johnny avec johnny juste
après lui
j'espère que je serai là même carrière
que lui j'espère vous pensez vous serez
dans 40 ans hop hop hop hop hop dieu
veut si dieu veut on sait jamais on sait
jamais vous pensez pas qu'à l'idée avec
tous ces changements de style comme ça
une fois et les rockers une fois il
chante des chansons une californienne
vous pensais pas que sa carrière va
s'arrêter il ya ici une telle belle bête
de scène c'est incroyable l'énergie
qu'ils dégagent
il est capable de tout faire beaucoup
beaucoup de choses en plus de ça j'ai
remarqué parce que j'ai quand même une
oreille bien avertis laquelle
à voir il a une voix sensationnaliste
touchante un maillot ni peut tout
chanter cloclo ça va durer le chlore
alors que le fossé
klaus et je lui souhaite une très longue
vie
[Applaudissements]
un haricot la france entière vous avez
couvert dans cinq colonnes à la une vous
êtes devenu vraiment une star en une
soirée grâce à la télévision
est ce que vous croyez que dans le 40
ans vous fêterez vos quarante ans de
carrière à la télé j'sais pas moi j'ai
fait un rêve prémonitoire d'aller me
voyez avec un homme en noir
ah ouais un homme en noir qui est tout
le temps habillés en noir un type qui
est la même qui va avoir la même voie
que vous est ce que vous croyez dans 40
ans michel drucker sera toujours là
drucker il est calé en sport il nous
fait des bourses d'europe des beaux
reportages je sais pas l'autre jour j'ai
dîné avec lui parce qu on est très
copain on va voir les matchs de foot
ensemble et ils rêvent de faire des
variétés un bon il rêve c'est d'animer
des des émissions de variétés tout ça je
le vois bien vous la voyez comment
l'algérie dans 40 ans quelle question
c'est difficile déjà je je digère à
peine le départ
vrai ben moi je souhaite que tout le
monde vive bien quoi 1 dans 40 ans et
que nous qui avons été déplacées
il n'y a pas si longtemps qu'on arrive à
se recycler qu'on arrive à bien
s'intégrer qu'on a vu il va bien se
faire aimer chez nous en france mais est
que et bien que l'algérie aussi soit
heureuse et si elle a choisi
l'indépendance et ben ouais quelque
chose moins de chance
est ce que vous préférez vous intégrez
comme il faut en france où retourner en
algérie
moi j'aime en tout cas je me rappelle de
ce qu'on m'a dit mon beau père avant sa
mort un jour avant sa mort il était venu
en france il avait fait un voyage et
puis il ne devait pas revenir parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup de rumeurs et des
complots qui sont 10es contre lui il me
dit je préfère mourir en algérie que de
vivre en france
[Applaudissements]
une dernière question avant de se
quitter abricots est ce que vous pensez
qu'un jour la france gagnera la coupe du
monde de football et moi je suis comme
la sncf est possible
[Musique]
m
4 merci d'avoir été avec nous
[Applaudissements]
15e jamais
à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant jean pierre
bourgeois
jean pierre bourgeois bonsoir vous
connaissiez abricots macias laurent
baffie vous êtes photographe et vos
premiers pas dans le métier ont eu lieu
en 1965 invitiez encore en classe de
première et puis vous devenez dans les
années qui suivent ce que l'on appelle
un photographe de charme vous vendez
votre premier sujet au journal lui en
1971 et vous dites page 95 du livre dont
nous allons parler j'ai toujours
respecté les femmes les voir comme des
images
ce n'est pas forcément les traiter comme
des objets malheureusement le 27 janvier
vous êtes accusé de proxénétisme vous
auriez contre rémunération présenté deux
jolies filles à des hommes d'affaires ou
à des princes saoudiens
la presse se déchaîne et le fameux juge
nguyen vous incarcère à fleury mérogis
hélas les charges contre vous ne font
que croître
vous auriez violet 27 modèles le juge
nguyen lance des commissions rogatoires
à travers le monde
robert de niro est sommé de s'expliquer
dans cette affaire et guillaume durand
était obligé de s'excuser au nom de la
france mesdames messieurs aujourd'hui un
jean pierre bourgeois venait expliquer
que c'est trop injuste avec un livre qui
s'appelle profession photographe
nul n'est à l'abri et un bandeau sur
lequel est écrit je n'ai jamais fait que
photographier des femmes
or le 27 janvier 97
quand vous rentrez chez vous après une
journée de travail vous trouvez votre
compagne natacha assises menotté oui je
suis arrivée à 4h30 de l'après midi et
puis j'ai ouvert ma porte et là je suis
j'ai trouvé quatre policiers
je pense excéder les bandits d'abord je
n'ai même pas que c'était la police
et puis montrer leur carte ils ont dit
voilà nous avons des dépositions faites
contre vous vous êtes accusé de
proxénétisme aggravé donc on vous emmène
du test et on va vous interrogez alors
on m'a interrogé exactement dix minutes
et je suis resté 48 heures en garde à
vue oui vous êtes accusé donc d'être à
la tête d'un réseau réseau internet
prostitution de luxe comme on dit accusé
de proxénétisme aggravé et on vous
reproche d'avoir utilisé votre métier
votre amie annie cabre une marque pour
attirer de jeunes filles donc dans ce
qu'on appelle prostitution haut de gamme
bref d'être un rabatteur en gros 1 pour
des riches clients de saint tropez de
mes amis de notre côté ça fait 25 ans
que je vais à saint tropez j'ai jamais
eu besoin de faire quoi que ce soit mais
18 sur place l avantage de saint tropez
j'ai jamais besoin de ça parce que quand
on travaille pendant 22 ans pour journal
lui un sujet jamais besoin de problème
donc gens viendront jouer après quelques
jours de garde à vue vous est incarcéré
à fleury-mérogis
ce que dit le juge nguyen c'est qu'il a
écouté une conversation téléphonique
entre vous et votre ami anika à bruz
marque où vous lui demandez de faire
venir deux filles à monaco pour un
prince saoudien
mais ça c'est une écoute qui a été
réalisée quand même et ça c'est
entièrement vrai mais la seule chose qui
a c'est que ce n'a jamais été pour une
relation sexuelle
ça a été pour un dîner pour les non non
attendez il faisait 250 kg ce pauvre
homme il risquait pas d'avoir une
relation sensuelle présente plus nommé
général les gros ils ont pas droit là
aussi mais il c'est pas pour ça c'était
pas pour sérieusement moi moi j'ai lu
votre bouquin en rempart la wii mais
c'est vrai que quand vous dites que vous
faites venir deux filles de paris à
monaco pour un prince saoudien et vous
dites que les filles en fait c'est
uniquement des pots de fleurs et c'est
juste pour l'accompagner leurs gènes
neige étaient convoqués pour le
photographier je ne le connaissais pas
je n'ai connu le 24 janvier
et comme par hasard le 27 j'étais arrêté
ce n'était pas une relation que j'avais
depuis longtemps je ne connaissais pas
cet homme
on m'a demandé de faire des photos pour
lui c'est un ami à moi libanais qui
m'avait demandé de photographier et dans
toutes mes relations saoudienne à part
monsieur khashoggi que j'ai connu quand
j'avais 17 ans c'est la seule personne
dharavi soit dit que j'ai connu il ya ça
effectivement et puis à ce libanais donc
là c'est très grave parce que c'est là
où on rentre complètement dans
l'histoire mon avocat vient me voir
après trois semaines d'incarcération à
fleury il m'a dit écoute j'ai réussi
enfin avoir une extraction tu va enfin
être interrogé et tu vas pouvoir être
confrontés à ceux qui t'ont qui ont dit
les choses sur toi mais je sais toujours
pas je ne les sucs eu trente secondes
avant de rentrer dans le bureau du juge
trois semaines après bon et là il y
avait marqué effectivement j'étais
accusé d'avoir travaillé pour l'émir du
qatar depuis 20 ans que je lui avais
présenté plus de cinquante filles et
qu'à chaque fois j'avais touché des
enveloppes de 50000 froid et je dis à
mon avocat qui étaient mes training à
l'époque j'ai dit mais paul ya un
problème ces fantômes à je connais pas
j'ai jamais vu l'émir du qatar qu'est ce
que je vais dire il m'a dit mon vieux
mais c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
défendre si tu peux pas prouver que tu
le connais pas tu es perdu on rentre
dans le bureau il me met au milieu il y
avait un hic à à ma droite et celui
banner la gauche bon je me dis si mais
interroge son premier qu'est ce que je
vais dire je peux pas dire c'est pas
vrai il faut que je prouve que c'est
parce qu'en france vous devez prouver
nous est innocent ça le problème
heureusement pour moi et labeur il a
interrogés indiquent à bruz mac dont
elle l a expliqué l ai dit écoutez il ya
cinq jean-pierre dans mon dossier
vous avez mis toutes les écoutes
téléphoniques au nom de jean-pierre mais
mon mari s'appelait jean pierre mon
directeur artistique s'appelle
jean-pierre alors il a remis en elle a
remis en ordre les conversations
téléphoniques dont j'étais déjà très
content parce que ces termes des charges
et puis après il a interrogé ce fameux
l'asie l'équipe est là il lui a dit
maintenant vous allez vous allez me
donner les dates les sols et l'argent
que monsieur bourgeois a touché avec
toutes les filles qu'il a présenté à
votre émir
puisque vous vous travaillez depuis
vingt ans pour se tenir il a dit la
chose suivante
excusez moi maintenant que je vois
monsieur bourgeois en face de moi ce
n'est pas lui
je me suis trompé de photographes il le
fait bien mon avocat s'est levé il lui a
dit il a dit au juge
attendez vous voyez bien que mon client
est innocent maintenant vous allez
libérer cette histoire c'est pas
possible
il connaît ni le prince fawaz il a
jamais vu de sa ville et l'émir du qatar
et le juge a dit non
on a commencé cette histoire on ira
jusqu'au bout et mon avocat lui a dit
attendez ça c'est puni c'est une enquête
normale ça devient un règlement de
comptes
prenez le comme vous voulez on ira
jusqu'au bout
les faits nous devons consacrer avant
pour moi vis-à-vis de monsieur bourgeois
et je ne reviendrai plus en arrière
là j'ai su ce jour là que j'étais perdu
oui voilà c'est terminé
au cours de l' enquête vous apprenez
qu'en plus vous êtes accusé par une
vingtaine de vos modèles d'attouchements
sexuels et de viols
c'est à dire que ce qui est dit
effectivement pas par ses fils a avant
de les faire entrer dans votre réseau de
prostitution internationales de luxe
vous profitiez d'elle selon un rituel
immuable et elle raconte tout la même
chose
rasage des poils pubiens pour la photo
application de crème apaisante et abus
sexuels tout alors la traîne pour la
mettre à prennent en main la langue pas
tout y en a eu seulement trois mais
attendez seulement 3 parce que ils ont
monté ils ont monté tout une enquête
tout une manipulation pour pouvoir me
garder en prison
alors on m'a mis des faux viol alors
cette venue des règlements de compte
des tentatives d'extorsion de fonds il a
fallu que j'attende 14 mois que tout se
passe parce que les avocats sont dûment
10 est perdus c'est fini à mon avis on
en a pour vingt ans s'est terminée j'ai
jamais fait ça évidemment parce que la
preuve vous allez là dira à la fin
puisque il ya quand même une preuve
c'est que j'ai 26 non lieu donc si j'ai
eu 26 non lieu c'est que on a monté une
agence canadienne soit remplacé par
moracchini qui a transformé les violets
que c'est une chanson n'est pas du
village une erreur de procédure nguyen
il a fait plus que ça il a fait une très
grave erreur c'est celle de robert de
niro
oui parce que c'est pas le fait
d'interroger robert de niro ça c'était
complètement débile robert de niro il
est venu déjeuner chez moi avec un ami à
moi qui s'appelle valtech feedback est
un joueur de tennis
maintenant je le connais je connaissais
depuis très longtemps j'ai on n'a pas
besoin de présenter deux filles monsieur
robert de niro il a tout ce qu'il faut
il n'a pas besoin de jean pierre
bourgeois pour rencontrer des filles
il est venu déjeuner et c'est vrai que
j'étais je travaille pour playboy
à cette époque là j'avais six mannequins
chez moi il y en a une qui l'a trouvé
très joli il est venu me voir il m'a dit
écoute
est ce que tu crois que je peux lui
demander son téléphone je dis boby n'a
pas besoin de moi si tu veux la revoir
tulard voix il a pris son numéro de
téléphone
un mois et demi après il a revu à
londres il il a fréquenté pendant un an
et demi il lui a envoyé cinq billets
d'avion parce qu'elle habitait long de
londres à new york et le juge a
considéré qu'à ça c'était un acte de
proxénétisme
parce qu'elle a eu un avantage de cinq
billets d'avion donc il m'a mis
proxénétisme internationales aggravées
pour ça ouais j'ai plongé
j'ai pu parler avec le jus julie
monsieur le juge je porte plainte je
dépose une requête en suspicion légitime
et je demande votre désistement j'estime
que seule une cour sera dire si je suis
coupable ou innocent la seule chose
qu'on lui a accordé la seule chose qu'on
lui a accordé c'est de nommer un autre
juge
c'est madame moracchini qui a été nommé
mais madame moracchini quand elle a vu
au bout de la quatrième
interview que c'était des tentatives
d'extorsion de fonds elle m'a mis 26 non
lieu mais ça a duré malheureusement 18
mois donc vous dites effectivement être
victime de l'acharnement du juge nguyen
et d'une machination dont vous ne seriez
pas la cible vous dites je ne suis pas
assez important sans doute voulait
t'emmerder des gens importants à travers
moi ces dérogations qui vous ai trouvé
l'explication serait visé si c'était pas
vous en l'occurrence bon il ya eu deux
personnes de viser dans mon affaire
la première c'était l'émir du qatar
pourquoi parce qu'il y avait il y avait
un problème d'armes dans le
d'armement en cours et il ya une manip
qui a été fait parce que l'émir du qatar
a été sommée aussi de venir voir le juge
alors non seulement il est pas il est
pas venu mais il est parti il a quitté
le crillon pour aller se retrouver au
dorchester à londres au pied
on n'a jamais plus entendu parler ici
son fils a téléphoné par utile aux
instances de la république qui a fait a
dit ok je n'achèterai plus les armes ici
je suis trésor américain donc j'ai servi
certainement de lampistes dans cette
histoire sans savoir qui est et qui
parce que moi j'ai jamais vu forte pour
moi dans le vignoble akata jamais vu et
qui d'autre alors j'ai un ami que je
connais depuis j'ai l'âge de 17 ans qui
avait très connu il y avait un passé
sulfureux
il a eu des non lieux et touche je ne
peux pas en parler aux farc ouvertement
jauge explique un petit peu dans mon
livre et c'est vrai que si j'avais pu
dire des choses sur tous mes amis je
veux bien vous croire à mais c'est vrai
parce que je n'oserais jamais eu 26 non
lieu oui mais enfin vous avez quand même
été condamné dans un premier temps à
cinq ans de prison
oui j'étais condamné à cinq ans de
prison mais quand j'ai été condamné à
cinq ans de prison
on m'a présenté devant la 16e chambre
avec toutes les accusations je n'ai eu
minant lieu quinze ans après si j'avais
été présenté devant monsieur thierry de
bonnefont avec 26 non lieu on n'aurait
jamais mis cinq ans de prison parce
qu'il m'a mis cinq ans de prison en hors
d'oeuvre en disant toute façon c'est pas
grave puisque vous allez prendre 20 ans
donc quand vous allez passer en cour
d'assises ans dans quelques mois
jean-claude mais quand vous avez été
condamné à cinq ans de prison pourquoi
ne pas avoir fait appel à l'heure
j'étais en prison
alors on est venu me voir mes avocats
vont me voir il m'a dit voilà il ya un
problème si tu fais appel
tu vas faire un an et demi encore de
prison par contre comme tu es une
conduite exemplaire était malade et que
tu as fait du social dans la prison
parce qu'effectivement je servais
l'écrivain pour tout le monde je suis
certainement le seul condamné à avoir
été avoir été condamné à cinq ans et
alors fake 24 mois ouais voilà les
filles jean pierre bourgeois y en a
beaucoup qui ont porté plainte contre
vous une fois que j'ai vu c'est non lieu
pourquoi ne pas les avoir attaqués pour
dénonciation calomnieuse
quand je suis sorti on m'a fait mon nom
mon enquête sur le criminel ou madame
marie qui nie ça a duré encore 7 mois ou
tous les trois jours j'allais la voir au
palais pour attendre les filles pour
avoir des confrontations l'une après
l'autre pour pouvoir expliquer
ce qui s'était passé avec chacune il y
aura que quatre qui sont venus que les
choses soient claires c'est tout savez
vous n'êtes pas 25 ans photographe d'un
journal comme le journal lui en
travaillant par monsieur philippe acquis
comme j'ai fait en ayant fait plein de
photos dans le monde entier et en
attendant l'âge de 46 ans pour avoir des
problèmes
ouais j'ai ça aurait eu bien l'avant
thierry bien avant si j'avais eu cette
conduite maintenant épiler ou rasé une
fille ou demander à une fille d'être
impeccable quand on fait photo venu j'ai
fait j'ai fait quand même rêver les gens
pour 10 me des dizaines d'années en ce
qui me concerne plus que jamais eu la
même après cette appréciation du dossier
on a eu un seul juge nguyen mais quand
on vous dit et ça il faut quand même que
vous le sachiez qu'à partir du moment où
vous avez une relation sexuelle avec une
femme et qu'il consacre on considère que
si celle-ci ou d'un jour une semaine un
mois ou un an après le regrette on
considère ça comme un viol
ouais vous êtes vraiment en danger mais
on a quelqu'un qui vous a connu à
l'époque
voici marlène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors même qu'une animatrice et elle est
bien connu vous travaillez aujourd'hui
atv madrid et en 1988 donc vous aviez 18
ans vous travaillez à l'époque pour une
agence de mannequins j'appelle agence
vip et bourgeois ici présent vous
propose d'aller faire des photos donc
dans un château en italie pour une somme
de 8000 francs de l'époque
c'est bien sa photo par elles mêmes vont
c'est et les photos de charme donc moi
ce qui m'intéressait à l'époque c'était
de gagner plus d'argent en faisant du
nuc en faisant un porte manteau dans le
prêt-à-porter
c'était la première fois que je pose nue
donc je ne savais pas exactement toutes
les parties de mon corps qu'il était en
train de prendre en photo exactement sur
les allées ou comment on va dire comment
ils y loue mais voilà les angles qui le
prenait en photo alors avancé à d'abord
dans la vie dans ce dans ce château en
italie le soir vous sortiez donc avec
jean pierre bourgeois y les deux autres
filles qui étaient là un mannequin on
faisait un peu on était invité dans le
château donc j'imagine que c'était un
accord qu'il avait avec le propriétaire
du château pour avoir le logement des
mannequins la bad en chameau qui était
assis à l'extérieur de rome et est
propriétaire du château sortait avec
vous dans les bois dans les restaurants
mais il nous en est tout le temps sortir
le soir on faisait un peu les escortes
quoi rire et de votre fleur comme une
jeune fille la wii est est ce que bon
donc vous sortirez dans des bois dans
les restaurants avec la propriétaire du
château sa jambière montjoie deux filles
deux filles on faisait les photos bon
moi j'ai aimé comme mon corps donc quand
vous reveniez le soir après les boîtes
de nuit il se passer quoi dans le
château madran château bon après ça a
continué bon bah la musique danser
on devait bon et file moi je ne vais pas
d'alcool donc rien pour moi il y avait
beaucoup de moments là il faisait un peu
la jambe alors le château qui avait un
peu des mains baladeuses un peu d'aidé
bah disons que je pense que là
propriétaire du château je crois qu'il
était très intéressé pour nous souhaiter
dessus quoi donc vous
enfin voilà quoi c'est clair j'imagine
qu'on n'était pas là bas non plus
seulement pour faire partie de décor du
château et comment vous faisiez vous
pour échapper à ses fins de soirée un
petit peu arrosée un plein dès que les
gitans peu fatigué parce que moi j'étais
venu pour faire mes photos dont je
voulais me coucher tôt je voulais être
fraîches le matin pour pour les photos
comme profession vieux visé je suis
fatigué je vais me coucher
oui voilà comme et puis surtout je
m'enferme à double tour ac les 20
restants j'ai fait les premières photos
avec marlène elles ont été très très
joli malheureusement elle fait doute un
petit peu de chirurgie après donc ça
correspondait plus à son corps initial
mais elle a été elle était elle j'ai
fait des photos avec elle qui était
sublime
sublime et puis je pense que mon ami
dont elle parle qui était un homme
extrêmement gentil qui était qui est un
de mes meilleurs amis je sais que
marlène la revue plus souvent fait
plusieurs fois après elle est resté
super copain avec lui ce qu'elle dit
marc même c'est qu'à la fin des prises
de vues dans ce château en italie vous
lui fait signer un contrat tout droit
pour 99 ans et vous le dites si tu me
signe pas ce contrat tout droit tu n'es
pas payé thierry oui c'est pas du tout
comme ça que ça se passe
non non non non ça a été comme ça
c'était une fois qu'on est dedans
château qu'on est obligé de signer ce
contrat qu'on n'a même pas pu faire lire
un avocat à personne et sur une demi
page chez j'ai bien souvenirs il y avait
autorisation droits d'image sur tout
support pendant 99 ans quelque chose qui
n'est pas non pas du tout légal alors
qu'est ce qu'on sait faire
du coup dire répondre est bondée là
dessus
ah bon vous répondrais pondéré ben bella
ciao j'ai 18 ans je viens de sortir de
chez les messieurs de chez mes parents à
jamais marqué 99 ans est de 92 ans
annonce deuxièmement je tiens quand même
à préciser ici ouvertement oui que
marlène m'a fait un procès à niveau de
ce contrat way et que je l' ai gagnée et
j'en viens et suis moi vous allez me
dire si c'est vrai ou pas vrai un jour
marlène dit ces photos je les retrouve
placardée en énormes dans les couloirs
et sur les quais du métro pour un point
36 15
même si ce cas c'est pas seulement les
grosses monsieur bourgeois ressort les
photos évidemment quand je commence à
être connu par la télévision m6 quand je
commence à faire être populaire par tf1
ou pour genève et n'importe quelle
chaîne
enfin toutes les émissions populaires
que j'ai fait en 95 elles ressortent
encore ces photos il n'arrête pas de les
ressortir en touche et en espagne
j'arrive en espagne 97 elles ressortent
encore un spécial je ne dirai pas le nom
du magazine 200 pages sur marlène
excusez moi parce que 97 ans 97 c'est
pas possible puisque j'étais en prison
ouais voilà donc c'est pas moi qui les
ai vendu les photos s'il vous plaît vous
pouvez pas porter le black coffee de
souvenirs la même chose que vous devez
savoir c'est qu'on m'a volé énormément
de matériel pendant que j'étais arrêté
et qu'il a fallu la parcelle que choisir
et blanche est désolé non
photo by laser et spéciale new look
management essec solo massage et
l'extraire de la télévision mais quand
j'ai vendu mes photos je les ai vendus à
nulle autre
la wii allait bien et dont je pourrais
me le passé alors je vais pas faire de
publicité c'est pas 97 cents je voudrais
que je trouve extraordinaire comme
monsieur bourgeois se permettent de
mettre ma photo quand j'avais 18 ans en
couverture d'une vidéo érotique et les
seuls qui font de la masturbation cédera
gisha et julia channel alors c'est moi
ça l'a couverte j'ai jamais travaillé
avec mais à l'intérieur il y en avait du
sexe avec les autres jeanne calment un
poil c'est pour ça qu'ils signent des
contrats de dix neuf ans mais pas vous
révéler foot ou aliou look c'est ce que
j'ai fait quand j'ai fait un sujet avec
marlène j'allais vendu à new look après
les propriétaires des droits c'est lui
qui les a ressorti et là je suis plus
propriétaires de ces droits
ces régions
j'en viens bourgeois je ne suis pas juge
on n'est pas ici pour vous juger
j'ai lu votre livre il ya quelque chose
que je comprends pas pourquoi vouloir
absolument vous disculper de tout ce que
vous avez fait pendant 25 ans en tant
que photographe de charme qu'elle quel
intérêt avez-vous à faire ça maintenant
attendez ma mère on est morte de chagrin
mon beau père est mort six mois après et
ma grand-mère huit mois après j'ai perdu
quasiment toute ma famille pour des
faits que j'ai jamais de montréal vous
avez quelque chose a ajouté jean-pierre
oui j'ai raconté mon histoire
j'ai bien expliqué exactement tout ce
qu'on a fait et je souhaite à personne
de connaître le parcours que j'ai pu
avoir
ok voilà merci
[Applaudissements]
ouais
alors oui comme vous le connaissez
bourgeois vous aviez l'air de le
connaître là c'est à dire que lui il me
connaît moi je me rappelle pas très bien
mais je sais qu'il a pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr c'est sûr qu'il a fait des
photos chez moi ça rasait et à raser un
puzzle dans les changements
il vous est arrivé les visages et vous a
pris en photo moi il m'a dit mais paie
les bons coups on peut pas savoir
un pass à moi j'ai un copain qui a été
vraiment ils étaient innocents mais j'en
ai été témoin il a été c'était en israël
que ça se passait et là il a il a été en
prison pendant deux ans parce qu'il
était accusé de viol coups et blessures
avec une femme de 45 ans oui ça une
américaine qui l'a accusé de llc
je me rappelle s'était brûlé les seins
avec des cigarettes mais c'est pas lui
je le connais et fermez là bas les
fumées mais c'était pas lui il sait
vraiment pas lui et il le verdict que
c'était 23 ans en prison
il a fait appel et la guinée a eu que
deux ans plus deux ans c'est quand même
énorme il a réussi à prouver son
innocence et ça mais c'est quand même
dur pour quelqu'un qui n'a rien fait de
c'est très cher et très très bon tu vas
pas faire la soirée là dessus a
maintenant maintenant moi ça me rappelle
une blague mais c'est une carrière c'est
c'est un type qui est accusé de viol
comme ça alors et le juge lui dis faites
fait entrer la victime est alors il ya
une femme qui arrive complètement
déchiré ravagé un oeil qui désavantage
les communs et me dit monsieur est ce
que vous reconnaissez la victime
comment suis je le reconnais je les
déchirer pour chaque oeil maintenant
elsa zylberstein
[Applaudissements]
elsa zylberstein alors on a beaucoup
pensé à vous et elsa récemment
effectivement au moment du décès de
maurice pialat puisque c'est un petit
peu grâce à lui que vous êtes là ce soir
aussi à l'époque vous tourniez van gogh
donc avec jacques dutronc et vous vous
deviez simplement assurer une silhouette
est une des filles au bord de l'eau quoi
et qui a l'a renvoyé la fille qui devait
jouer la prostituée et vous êtes dit ça
va tomber sur moi et c'est tombé sur
nous c'est vrai que c'est des moments où
destin vous êtes vous donner un coup de
pouce et je n'oublierai jamais ça et
c'était la chance d'avoir un grand
réalisateur est un homme merveilleux et
qui était mon maître et mon père oui
parce qu'après vous avez fait doute film
vous avez féminin tennenbaum farinelli
jefferson à paris l'homme est une femme
comme les autres avec antoine j'ai été
pas mal de beaux films mais vous avez
quand même continuer toujours avoir
pialat oui c'est quelqu'un de très
important pour moi c'est quand on
commence avec quelqu'un je pense est
important d'être fidèle et c1 c'est du
caviar de commandes avec lui c'est
quelqu'un c'est vraiment un génie du
cinéma c'est un génie mais qui ne veut
pas qu'on lui dise ah il n'aimait pas
qu'on lui dise qu'on l'aimé
mais vous savez je pense que c'est
important de pouvoir détruire ce qu'on
est en train de faire dès lors on est
content de soi on avance plus je pense
que c'est important de se dire c'est pas
bien ce qu'on fait tout cas je peux me
remettre en question c'est comme un
peintre qui serait en train de faire une
toile qui voudraient toujours retouché à
sa toile
je pense que c'est le propre même d'un
artiste vouloir repasser par là où il
est passé
en tout cas de regarder plus loin et de
se dire c'est pas bien ce que j'ai fait
avant et je pense qu'on peut avancer que
comme ça alors c'est pialat qui vous a
conseillé de garder votre nom parce que
vous hésitiez peut-être s'appelait
stener peut-être s'appelait zilber
c'était la grande question est un jour
voulu dit bah finalement stener déjà y
avait déjà des affiches qui étaient
imprimés pour une pièce avec georges
wilson avec marqué avec marquez est
nerfs il vous a listé nord c'est une
marque de canapés tu vas pas je suis
papa t'appeler stener garde ton nom ça
sera plus simple
alors quand vous tournez jefferson à
paris vous devenez ami
pendant le tournage avec gwyneth paltrow
et vous êtes devenu très proche de sa
famille non c'est vous aussi vos amis
américains américaine lorsque très
étonnant c'est que vous allez reprendre
au théâtre la preuve qu'ils étaient
créés par win elle a joué à londres et
en fait c'est drôle quand elle l'a joué
à lons elle m'a dit c'est dommage que tu
la joues pas à paris et puis on m'a
demandé de la jouer il ya un mois donc
c'était assez incroyable alors la preuve
de david o byrne dans l'adaptation de
jean claude carrière mise en scène de
bernard murat avec michel aumont qui
remplace rufus avec anne loiret qui
remplace anne consigny
c'est au théâtre des mathurins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous disiez là parce que
les gens veulent toujours savoir quand
ils regardent la télé il mais qu'est ce
qu'ils peuvent se dire d'abord je disais
que quel rôle est joué mais elle me dit
le rôle du mathématicien dray et puis je
disais que je l'adoré parce que ça fait
très longtemps que j'assumais puis elle
m'a même invité au théâtre c'est très
bien alors le piste de cette pièce vous
fêtez vos 27 ans avec votre brillant
mathématicien de pair
alors ce qui est très bizarre c'est que
votre père vous c'est un grand physicien
c'est très rigolo parce que vous jouez
le rôle d'un grand mathématicien
simplement il est mort quelques jours
plus tôt dans la pièce et il ya un
étudiant qui arrive qui s'appelle hall
et qui vous demande d' encore pouvoir
étudier les notes laissées par ce génie
qui était votre votre père et découverts
avant de mourir une chose que tout le
monde cherchait une chose très compliqué
à trouver un et vous vous dites que
c'est vous qui l'avez trouvée mystère
non ce qui est beau c'est une pièce sur
sur la passion sur la confiance sur
l'amour c'est une pièce drôle et
émouvante et c'est vrai que c'est un
rôle magique une vraie héroïne de 2 t à
c'est une vraie héroïne mais c'était une
des vraies grandes créations de la
rentrée c'est une des pièces qui est le
plus marqué la la rentrée théâtrale
effectivement at-elle hérité du génie ou
de la folie de son père sur l'hérédité
effectivement c'est une pièce sur sur
les preuves d'amour en fait je trouve en
forme l'alsace maman comment ça se passe
à ce sujet très savez de répéter
apprécié cette heure par jour ça on est
battu mais des fois vous êtes un peu
timide comme ça un peu renfermé
là je comprends les extravertis à bombay
ça fait plaisir bon là tant mieux non
j'adore cette pièce j'adore ce
personnage je trouve c'est un rôle
magnifique et c'est une pièce que
beaucoup de gens j'aimerais que les gens
y viennent parce que c'est les gens qui
sont généralement dire le théâtre c'est
une pièce vraiment abordable et
émouvante et drôle et on passe une
soirée assez incroyable je trouve je
suis allé en vacances
elle est bonne en promo libre lancé
parce qu'elle est authentique et parce
qu'elle est sincère
ouais c'est la basse et qu'elle n'a pas
la grosse tête et je me fais plaisir
après les choletais
et
alors il ya une autre actu évidemment
c'est le film d'antoine comment il va
antoine il est content du film ravi ça
se passe bien entre vous vous êtes
toujours ensemble et non mais ça fait
quand même temps maintenant et vous
savez quand même temps que vous êtes en
20 ans 5 ans et vous avez commencé plus
tard voilà comment ça se passe après
avoir dit moi très bien non franchement
langage de la vérité là derrière dit
alors la réalité coup tu sais ça fait 20
ans et j'attends toujours calme at-elle
et j'espère qu'elle attend que je
l'appelle de temps en temps non cela
veut dire qu'elle m'appelle sa mort le
premier rôle
le premier rôle que j'ai joué dans un
film c'est le rôle d'un père je pouvais
jamais joué le rôle de son père avec les
yeux callaway personne ne me croit
tu as envie de larrazet temps
[Applaudissements]
alors donc le film d'antoine s'appelle
monsieur n avec philippe torreton
scénario d'antoine de caunes et de rené
manzor alors le pitch donc un film qui
parle de napoléon à l'époque où il est à
sainte hélène
alors le pitch est un jeune officier
anglais dont la mission était de
surveiller napoléon à sainte-hélène et
qui mène 20 ans plus tard une enquête
sur la mort de l'empereur
alors c'est une piste il ya beaucoup de
théorie sur la mort ou la no more ou de
napoléon à sainte-hélène
ça c'est une piste sur la disparition du
corps de cipriani qui était donc le
majordome de l'empereur napoléon est en
fait le corps qui serait aux invalides
serait le corps de ceux ci prix n y est
pas le corps de napoléon gsm c'est le
micro qui me chatouille derrière alors
vous voulez vous attention ça coûte cher
j'ai 24 témoignage contre moi je m'en
suis sentiers alors donc voilà donc le
corps qui se colle aux invalides serait
pas celui de napoléon bonaparte mais
celui du dénommé cipriani majordome de
l'empereur laurent baffie voilà tu suis
voilà on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
magnéto serge
[Musique]
qui occupe le tombeau de l'empereur se
cacher au peuple
trois mille hommes du bâtiment de guerre
tous cas pour garder un général fo cfdt
une chose en string band et mis les
bases match nul devant toulouse a
caracolé 18 ans qui se passe est
différente l'aise mais mais
j c l'empereur ne vous aime pas lui
harris et blanc
la taille importante c'est la dernière
la dernier on essaie de poisson
ça faisait partie du plan
il s'est passé quelque chose de sauter
l'empereur at il remporté cette
mystérieuse bataille est une mort
d'homme libre
l'histoire est un mensonge que personne
ne conteste
voilà monsieur nouveau film d'antoine de
caunes servir classe à moi j'ai pas
encore vu les salaires classe à c'est
pas un film historique lourd c'est en
fait un thriller psychologique qui se
passe à sainte-hélène donc les dernières
années de la vie de napoléon
effectivement le film se base sur un
fait réel c'est que l'oxo le tombeau du
meilleur ami de napoléon cipriani
évident
bah oui et donc en fait la thèse
éventuelle du film c'est que napoléon
n'est pas aux invalides et c'est très
possible
donc en fait voilà après il ya un fils
comme ça qu'ils se tirer c'est un film
très tendue c'est un film très élégant
d'une pureté absolue et je trouve assez
brillant se débrouille bien hâte et des
formidables
[Rires]
on a fait la pièce on est en finale ça
c'est fait laurent question pensais pas
qu'on parle des photos maintenant
[Musique]
m
g
il a témoigné
envoyé à m
[Musique]
j'accueille m'attend mohamed sifaoui
bonjour alors mohamed sifaoui bonsoir
vous êtes journaliste vous collaborez à
marianne et à la voix du luxembourg et
vous êtes déjà auteur au cherche midi
d'un livre qui s'appelle la france
malade de l'islamisme et aujourd'hui
vous publiez toujours au cherche midi
mes frères assassin comment j'ai un
filtre est une cellule d'al qaïda
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors dans ce livre vous racontez
comment par pur hasard vous retrouver à
paris un algérien qui dans les années 80
avait fréquenté le même lycée que vous
et qui est devenu un islamiste radical
ce qu'on appelle un terroriste et qui
vous fait entrer dans le réseau
alors on va prendre les choses à zéro
vous êtes musulman d'origine algérienne
et vous prenez le risque c'est
évidemment pas par désir de célébrité
c'est évidemment pas par héroïsme nous a
dit que c'est par conviction
c'est par conviction parce que ma
conviction est la suivante l'islamisme
l'intégrisme musulman est une forge lui
une forme de fascisme qui n'a rien à
envier au nazisme et a gelé déjà écrit
j'ai maintes fois eu l'occasion de
l'écrire
quand on a combattu le nazisme quand on
a combattu le fascisme
on peut pas ne pas combattre l'islamisme
qui aujourd'hui et représente le danger
que représentait le nazisme il y a
quelques années si on l'avait combattu
avant qu'il ne s'installe en allemagne
et si on avait combattu le fascisme
avant qu'il ne s'installe dans certains
pays peut être que l'histoire aurait pu
éviter un certain nombre de drames et
peut-être que l'histoire aurait pu
éviter aux populations civiles notamment
un certain nombre de cauchemar comme
ceux qui ont été vécues pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
donc depuis 95 effectivement les
attentats sur le sol français vous
intéresser à ce qui se passe ça pas
commencé le 11 septembre ce qui vous
concerne et vous assistez donc un jour
au procès des gens qui sont accusés de
ces attentats
et vous remarqué un homme d'une
trentaine d'années barbu queue de cheval
tenu pakistanaise alors cet homme vous
décidez d'aller le voir et quand vous le
rencontrez vous dit vous étiez pas au
lycée emir abdelkader à bab el oued et
vous à ce moment-là coup de génie tu dis
oui oui ça s'est passé comme ça parce
qu'effectivement j'ai passé une année
dans cet établissement scolaire moi je
ne me rappelais pas du tout de son
visage ouais il me disait absolument
rien moi il m'intéressait parce que
j'avais vu que c'était un islamiste qui
venait tous les jours
narguer d'abord les parties civiles
qui étaient quittés nombreuses et par
ailleurs qui salué les accusés qui avec
lesquels ils échangeaient des clins
d'oeil et wallons j'étais mes pulsions
journalistique poussé à aller vers lui
et pour voir pourquoi ils venaient
pourquoi ils s'intéressaient à ce procès
quel lien avait-il avec avec les deux
mis en cause et donc c'est là où il me
dit effectivement qu'ils m'ont visage
lui disait quelque chose et qu'il
m'aurait vu dans un lycée en à gérer ce
qui était vrai et donc par la suite nous
avons livré une relation qui a donné qui
est cet homme
cet homme c'est un jeune algérien
c'est ce qui était extraordinaire en
fait pour moi aussi c'est que s'il y
avait une grande symbolique dit qu'on
avait fréquenté le même lycée qu'on est
issu de deux quartiers séparés peut-être
de 3 4 km
vingt ans après moi je suis journaliste
écrivain lui il est islamiste déjà
condamné dans une affaire de terrorisme
dire de 13,2 trajectoire qui sont quand
même diamétralement diamétralement
opposées caisse alors je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de vous poser la question
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en algérie
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour
qu'une partie de la population pète les
plombs
passez moi l'expression et dérives de
cette manière pour ensuite penser que
tous ceux qui ne sont pas avec eux sont
à éliminer sont à combattre y sont à
tuer donc cet homme c'est un islamiste
convaincu 1 qui a déjà été arrêté en
1998 à la veille de la coupe du monde de
football
vous le décrivez comme un gros poisson
comme un terroriste et voulu promettez
de mener une enquête en tant que
journaliste pour démontrer l'innocence
des accusés dans les attentats de paris
il vous propose des cours de religion
tout de suite immédiatement
immédiatement après le procès
on s'était mis d'accord pour nous revoir
régulièrement et là il m'a appris que il
enseignait il donnait des cours de
religion dans une mosquée au coeur de
paris et il m'a proposé de venir
rejoindre ses cours et c'est là où j'ai
découvert qu'en fait c'était lui qui
avait rang de doctrine et jamel harvey
l'oiseau dont on a beaucoup parlé en
france et qui ce jeune ce jeune français
qui qui
qui a trouvé la mort dans les grottes de
tora bora en afghanistan
donc naturellement là je ne pouvais pas
ne pas m'intéresser aux personnages
parce que non seulement il s'intéressait
aux auteurs des attentats de 95 mais
aussi il
il avait formé un certain nombre de
jeunes français qui s'était retrouvé en
afghanistan j'ai cité djamel loiseau il
ya aussi samir farag à qui est mort en
afghanistan il ya brahim yadel qui est
détenus actuellement à guantanamo
donc tous ces jeunes et d'autres sont
passés par cette mode hawks et santé en
doctrine entre autres par lui et par lui
donc c'est quelqu'un d'important comment
vous expliquez qu'il voulait ce
l'approché assez facilement vous achetez
un cahier pour travailler les dogmes et
les principes de la djihad enfin c'était
assez facile quand même y'a pas de
d'examen de passage ya pas de d'épreuves
ya pas deux est-ce qu'il a pris des
renseignements sur vous non moi ce qui
est ce qui a été ce qui m'a aidé un
petit peu a approché à gagner sa
confiance c'est je le dit modestement je
cognais je connais bien ma religion
d'abord mais je connais mieux encore
cette idéologie qui nourrit leur maison
leur dessein maca connaissant le
wahhabisme et le salafisme
j'ai utilisé le discours qui nous est
cher parce que étant fascistes ne neige
pas j'étais face à des fascistes
naturellement si je reporte est la
contradiction il n'accepterait jamais de
me parler être qu'il me combattre est la
seule manière de les approcher serait de
leur tenir un discours un qu'ici à leurs
oreilles c'est ce que j'ai fait ça
marche et ça marchait alors lui bat son
job c'est de centraliser l'argent pour
la cause
il vous demande de l'aider il vous dit
si c'est des frères il faut dire que
l'argent c'est pour les prisonniers
et si ce n'est pas des frères il faut
dire que l'argent c'est pour les pauvres
donc on voit comment ça se passe et qui
donne cet argent l'argent en fait
provient de différentes sources
moi celles que j'ai pu voir ou observer
d'abord la naïveté des musulmans parce
que je tiens à le dire il ya aujourd'hui
un peu plus de 5 millions de musulmans
en france la majorité la majorité n'ont
rien à voir avec ce type d'individu et
je tiens à le signaler
on le dit souvent il met la majorité
aussi est très naïf donc quand ils
voient un barbu devant une mosquée avec
un carton à la main
disons pour les pauvres 5 euros s'il
vous plaît et bah il donne hélas je
voudrais lancer un message
justement à la communauté musulmane
d'abord mais aussi aux autorités pour
que cet argent et le financement du
culte musulman soit réglementée il faut
absolument que cette question soit
réglée parce que pour eux ça reste comme
le nerf de la guerre
celle cet argent servira peut-être à
commettre des attentats sur le sol
français
alors un moment vous lui dites que vous
voulez aller accomplir le jihad
et il vous conseille d'aller vous
entraîner en tchétchénie il en fait ils
m'avaient plusieurs fois passé fait
passer le message comme ça pour me sont
des émois une fois alors le jour on a eu
cette conversation je lui pose la
question je lui dis je vois que tu te
pousse tout le monde à y aller mais toi
pourquoi tu n'y vas pas mais je les dis
je les ai dit ça d'une certaine manière
pour qu'il n'ait pas pour ne pas le
vexer
donc là il me dit moi mon rôle est de
rester en france parce que je maîtrise
les deux longues et les deux langues
pardon et parce que je peut inciter
encourager les jeunes à aller faire le
tient donc sa mission son rôle et
consiste à encourager les gens à les
faire le djihad
donc ils m'encouragent à les faire le
djihad il m'encourage avant d'aller
m'entraîner en tchétchénie et je lui dis
pourquoi tu n'y vas pas donc je le
relance il me dit ce sont les
théologiens qui qui me qui m'empêche d'y
aller un jeudi mais qui les théologiens
il me dit ben le cheikh salman et jeudi
mais c'est qui le cheikh salman ben il
dit comment tu connais pas le sheikh
salman salle malouda le saoudien le
grand le grand le grand théologien
saoudien qui a formé les quinze 15 des
auteurs des attentats du 11 septembre
naturellement je connaissais ce cher
mais je voulais qu'il le dise je voulais
je voulait l'entendre de sa propre
bouche pour pourvoir et pour constater
et observer qu'en fait ces jeunes
reçoivent leurs ordres d'abord de
l'étranger notamment de l'arabie
saoudite notamment tout ce qui est sûr
le plan dogmatique
idiot logique ça c'est l'arabie c'est le
voilà tout ce qui est opérationnel tout
ce qui est terrorisme c'est à partir de
londres et c'est à partir de la grande
motte à dire à partir de tous ces
islamistes qui sont basés à quelqu'un
à quelques kilomètres des côtes
françaises s'il vous avait demandé de
faire un attentat
vous pensez bien que j'ai longuement
réfléchi à cette possibilité
j'avais décidé que le jour où je verrais
que les limites du travail
journalistique avait été atteinte
j'arrêterai tout naturellement vous
pensez bien que si j'avais eu
connaissance d'un d'une prépa de la
préparation d'un attentat ce sera pas le
journaliste qui aurait agi mais le
citoyen j'aurais alerté les autorités la
police j'aurais j'aurais appelé le 17
j'aurais tout fait pour que cet attentat
n'est pas nul alors vous parlez mohamed
sifaoui de l'implantation des islamistes
notamment à paris à belleville vous
dites qui est tenue vraiment par les
islamistes et entre eux ils parlent de
territoires libérés ou d'états
islamiques
c'est assez anecdotique parce que mes à
la fois dramatique et très symbolique de
leur de leurs projets ça a été dit dans
une discussion comme ça en passant
on me dit voilà là on est dans des
années dans des territoires libérés
on est dans des républiques islamiques
c'est à dire il arrive à créer des mini
république islamique y compris dans
certaines dans certains quartiers dans
certaines je veux dire je veux pas dire
banlieue parce que c'est trop
stigmatiser les banlieues mais dans
certains quartiers il arrive à créer
quand même des mini république islamique
où ils interdisent aux tenanciers de
cafés de vendre de l'alcool où ils
interdisent la vente du porc oui ils
interdisent de se marier avec sa valeur
tout ça c'est c'est dit c'est fait en
fait dans une omerta souvent est
terrible parce que les gens sont
pétrifiés face à ce sujet il faut le
dire
les gens ont peur les gens ne savent pas
comment réagir parce que souvent les
gens quand ils ouvrent leur gueule comme
c'est mon cas aujourd'hui
eh ben il reste se retrouvé seul après
les risques de payer les pots cassés
tout seul enrico quand on entend mohamed
sifaoui dont je vois pas pourquoi on
remettra et la parole en doute par les à
belleville de territoires libérés d'état
islamique
c'est grave non oui mais ce qu'est ce
qu'il ya d'extraordinaire ce soir c'est
le témoignage de mohamed sifaoui je suis
bluffé je me serais attendu à tous mais
ce soir je suis époustouflée et en même
temps très heureux de d'écouter ce
témoignage parce que ça prouve qu'il y à
un mouvement qui se prépare à
l'intérieur d'eux
de la communauté musulmane qui va
s'élever contre l' amalgame qu'on est en
train de faire et justement ces gens là
qui veulent un état islamique
ça me rappelle les charles martel désert
mais enfin bon c'est vrai c'est un réel
danger dans le monde entier oui ils ont
commencé à le prouver depuis le 11
septembre
et puis aussi les kamikazes des
attentats en israël et tout ça qu'on en
oublie de signaler en ce qui concerne
tout de même cette question israélo
palestinienne
parfois j'ai l'impression qu'on a qu'on
a peur ou honte de dire les choses comme
elles sont ben moi je vais vous dire ce
que je pense je condamne fermement les
attentats qui visent les civils en
israël et il n'y a aucune différence
pour moi entre un terroriste palestinien
un terroriste islamiste parce qu'un
terroriste est un terroriste quelqu'un
qui visent des civils pour je ne sais
quoi pour je ne sais quel quels
objectifs pour un territoire ou pour je
ne sais quoi d'autre pour avoir un peu
quand il ya une guerre eh ben on la mène
contre des contres des gens armés
je vais vous dire le coran ce qu'il dit
est la religion la religion musulmane ce
qu'elle dit dans sedan à ce sujet vous
pouvez demander à n'importe quel
théologiens musulmans
il vous le dira la première bataille
menée par les musulmans la bataille de
badr le prophète avait demandé à ses
compagnons de ne pas s'attaquer aux
vieillards de ne pas s'attaquer aux
femmes de ne pas s'attaquer aux enfants
de ne pas couper les arbres de ne pas
polluer l'atmosphère de ne pas
c'est-à-dire polluer les lots et de nous
combattre il leur a dit combattez que
ceux qui vous combattent c'est à dire
que ceux qui ont les armes à la main
ça vous savez ça voulait dire quoi ça
voulait dire voilà les règles du jeu on
est en guerre
certes mais on est en guerre cette
guerre doit être codifié je n'ai pas
aujourd'hui l'impression que ce qui se
passe en israël c'est codifié selon des
termes musulmane c'est une barbarie
aveugle on va on va exploser comme ça
dans une boîte de nuit dans un café et
il y aura peut-être parmi les civils qui
seront tuer des gens qui sont pour la
cause palestinienne
il s'est passé des moments comme ça donc
content qu'il ait répondu à ma place
mais non mais c'est vrai je pense
exactement la même chose ça fait plaisir
ce soir c'est extraordinaire on a
beaucoup avancé
moi j'aimerais savoir au niveau de votre
sécurité je trouve ça très corrigé
encourager votre démarche
est ce que vous êtes soutenus par votre
communauté ou est-ce que vous n'êtes ni
sur le banc et est ce que ça a changé au
quotidien pour vous ce se livrer écoutez
ce livre je vois que vous êtes mariés
après ce n'est pas rien quand est ce que
vous faites
ce livre est sorti aujourd'hui je n'ai
rien changé à mes habitudes je ferai
tout pour ne rien changé à mes habitudes
parce que j'ai vu d'autres confrères à
travers le monde mener ce genre banque
est parfois dans des milieux mafieux ou
ou de banditisme ça s'est très mal
terminée pas assez souvent terminé par
une dépression nerveuse par un suicide
des couples qui qui qui éclate je suis
très vigilant par rapport à ça et ma
force aujourd'hui
si c'est si tenté que ça soit ça soit
une force ce que personnellement j'ai
vécu en algérie sama blindé de
l'intérieur et un jour j'ai pris la
décision et c'est est la suivante les
terroristes n'arriveront jamais à
terroriser jamais
bien
il ya quelques semaines il ya quelques
semaines dans cette émission
l'abbé de la morandais disait quand il y
avait la torture pendant la guerre
d'algérie il disait moi et quelques
autres comme le général de la
bollardière on s'est élevé contre la
torture pratiquée par l'armée française
en algérie ils n'étaient pas nombreux et
ils ont eu raison
et il disait aussi ils avaient de
l'amendé qu'il attendait que des
musulmans aujourd'hui s'élèvent contre
ces islamistes contre ces terroristes et
je crois qu'on est heureux d'en voir ce
que vous ne savez pas peut-être
certainement vous ne savez pas c'est que
à ce jour les musulmans ont pays ont
payé le prix fort contre l'islamisme en
egypte en algérie et dans beaucoup de
pays musulmans dès islamistes ont
d'abord commencé à tuer des musulmans
avant d'étendre leur d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que je dis en vrai dans le
subconscient collectif occidental
tous ces morts qui qui ont payé de leur
vie leur le barrage qu'il voulait faire
à ce fascisme qu'est l'islamisme
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas été
comptabilisés on a commencé à faire
tourner le compteur qu'à partir du 11
septembre 2001 c'est vrai alors mohamed
sifaoui quelle est la découverte la plus
inquiétante que vous ayez faite durant
votre enquête
la découverte
si c'en est une parce que je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas eu le temps de vérifier la
crédibilité de l'information qui m'a été
communiqué c'est que il comptait
réellement et là je ne voudrais pas
passer pour un alarmiste et
mon but n'est pas de faire en sorte à ce
que l'opinion publique sorte demain dans
dans un être dans un autre état d'esprit
voyez je n'ai pas envie que demain les
français sortent dans la rue en
soupçonnant tous maghrébins qu'il qui
pourrait qu'il pourrait croiser auto
musulmans qui pourrait croiser ce qui
m'a fait peur ce qui me fait peur c'est
que j'ai entendu je les ai entendu
parler de la possibilité d'un attentat
en france et en fait ça m'a été dit à
plusieurs reprises la première fois
c'était à la suite de du message qui
avaient été diffusés par al-jazira le
message de ben laden dans lequel il
avait annoncé mis en garde des pays
comme la france l'italie l'allemagne
l'angleterre et le canada est là dans ce
message en fait le ils ont décrypté
qu'il donné l'ordre à toutes les
cellules agissant dans ces pays-là de
passer à l'action
et donc on ma on m'a dit que dans la
stratégie d'al qaïda s'était il fallait
perpétrer un attentat extraordinaire
veut dire type 11 septembre
une fois tous les deux ans pour marquer
les esprits histoire de dire nous sommes
toujours là donc derniers attentats de
j'ai entendu dire qu'il préparait
quelque chose pour l'année 2003 en
europe pour revendiquer notamment la
libération des détenus de guantanamo
c'est ce qui s'est passé à la courneuve
quand même trois individus qui ont été
arrêtés
justement le 16 décembre la dst arrête à
la cité des 4000 à la courneuve
trois individus qu'ils préparaient un
attentat wima visiblement moi je n'ai
pas toutes les données pour dire si
réellement ces trois préparer un
attentat et en france ce qui a été
découvert sur surprenant parce que une
tenue nv c'est quand même bien joué
c'est donc c'est une tenue pour quand on
manipule et des produits chimiques
c'est quand même un traître plus que
suspect par ailleurs
c'est la première fois qu'on parle qu'on
évoque la préparation d'attentats en
angleterre donc deuxième payer pays qui
a été citée par ben laden et
l'angleterre qui a été durant de longues
années un sanctuaire pour les islamistes
books avait étudié le problème de
l'intérieur est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils sont assez flics et ils sont
assez surveillé ou d'après ce que vous
en avez vu ils sont trop nombreux ou
trop caché qu'ils peuvent agir comme bon
leur semble d'une certaine façon
non je pense qu'ils sont surveillés sur
tous ceux qui ont déjà été arrêtés et
condamnés
un contraste est incontestablement ils
doivent être surveillés simplement le
danger c'est qu'ils arrivent à recruter
de nouveaux adeptes très rapide mais
relativement rapidement d'une part
d'autre part ils ont une mobilité qui
est assez fréquent c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui en france peu
dix jours après se retrouver en
angleterre sous une autre sous avec un
faux passeport de faux papiers et donc
avec un autre nom et est généralement
avant de préparer quelque chose il
il est vous avez des cellules logistique
qui prépare le terrain qui font les
repérages qui font tout ce qu'il y a
affaire qui ramène de l'argent et tout
mais vous avez les opérationnels c'est à
dire ceux qui vont commettre des
attentats suicides cela généralement ne
sont pas connus des services de sécurité
je vous renvoie à l'attentât de djerba
qui a été commis par quelqu'un qui n'ait
quitté complètement inconnu des services
de sécurité et qui n'a jamais eu affaire
à la justice
et donc ce sont ce genre d'individus je
crois qu'ils font peur aux services de
police et aux services judiciaires
honnêtement je ne sais pas quoi dire
parce que on va on va rester on va
passer à des pilotes de votre bouquin
beaucoup de gens qui sont contre
l'intervention américaine et voire
européennes en irak disent que ça
réveille rsa accroîtrait encore le
terrorisme islamiste est ce que vous
qu'ils avaient fréquenté qui les avait
connus d'assez près est ce que vous
pensez qu'une attaque contre saddam
hussein qui est un laïc qui n'est pas un
religieux c'est pas l'imam khomeiny
est-ce que vous pensez que ça serait de
nature à augmenter leur volonté de
commettre des attentats je vais vous
dire tous les intégristes que j'ai
fréquenté attendre cette guerre avec
impatience ils l'appellent de leurs
voeux
pourquoi c'est tout simple aujourd'hui
ce qui est recherché par ben laden et
ses émules
c'est réellement ce choc des
civilisations dont on paraît en cherche
à multiplier les guerres entre le monde
musulman et le monde occidental est donc
pour eux si vous vous laissez pas c'est
pas cette dame et ça c'est pas comme
dans le conflit israélo palestinien
c'est par arafat où c'est encore moi le
peuple palestinien qui les intéressent
mais ce conflit les intéresse parce que
ça reste un abcès de fixation
donc tout ça qu'est ce que ça va faire
ça va alimenter les haines ça va
alimenter encore une fois les patients
ça va diviser davantage les communautés
en ce qui concerne la france et ça va
faire que demain ben un jeune qui
d'abord n'arrive pas à trouver du
travail qui est peut être sujet à une
forme ou une autre de discrimination qui
clique et mal dans sa peau qui
n'arrivent pas à s'intégrer et ben il va
trouver refuge dans la religion il va se
retrouver demain transformés en bombes
humaines
voilà ce que les américains veulent
veulent nous faire vivre
alors on continue l'histoire donc le
lendemain de l'arrestation des trois
terroristes la cité des 4000 à la
courneuve
votre contact est arrêté et donc vous
vous sortir de là vous allez quand même
à la prière du vendredi
et vous dites aux gens qui sont là avec
vous que vous avez été convoqué par la
police ce qui expliquera qui nous
verrons plus quand quand il a été arrêté
moi j'ai décidé de
de me retirer et comme si la chose
disons il y avait quelque chose qui me
rattraper quatre jours après et il est
mis en garde à vue quatre jours après il
est relâché parce que parce que il n'y
avait pas assez de preuves visiblement
contre lui donc là il avait arrêté dans
une hausse pour une autre affaire dans
la banque
actuellement il en prison il a été
arrêté hier mais le fait de passer à la
télévision comme ça tu seras que
qu'est-ce que le disque est pas qu on
reconnaisse que après tout ce que vous
avez fait écouter on dit qu on ne me
reconnaîtra certainement je suis je
revendique je signe le livre de mon nom
j'ai pris position donc sur ça il ya
c'est irréversible
simplement je leur répondrai en termes
religieux
il y a inversé dans le coran qui dit la
chose suivante et je ne traduit pas je
le dit en substance si les êtres humains
et les démences associe contre toi pour
te faire pour te faire du mal
ils ne pourront se faire que ce que dieu
ta personne a prescrit et si les déments
et les êtres humains s'associent pour
toi pour te faire du bien et ne pourront
se faire que ce que dieu a prescrit donc
moi je suis croyant il ne pourra arriver
que ce que dieu m'a prescrit inch'allah
[Applaudissements]
oui merci ben oui généralement les gens
qui vivent dans cette émission faire des
témoignages un peu grave comme ça quitte
le plateau après leur témoignage
mais moi j'ai envie quand même de
montrer qu'au delà de tout ça on peut
être musulman à avoir là ce que vous
avez parlé s'amuser est ce que vous
acceptez de rester avec nous jusqu'à la
fin de la mission
ça serait avec plaisir d'autant plus que
je suis un fan de votre émission merci
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant moi je reste la tâche
[Musique]
à tous ceux personnes
pas si natacha amal
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
eh bien natacha amal bonsoir enrico
macias elsa zylberstein bras mais aussi
sur la mamba laurent baffie est marraine
moreau va aussi c'est de la bombe
diba fille très bien alors vous êtes la
juge la plus sexy de la télé un héroïne
d'une série sur tf1 qui s'appelle femmes
de loi et puis vous êtes aussi avec le
commissaire moulin mais entendu et vous
allez être l'héroïne de bleu océan à la
série estivale de tf1
voilà vous avez les cheveux magnifiques
merci vous savez pourquoi des jeux mais
parce qu'elle dort
natacha avec de lamoise de bob sur la
tête
t'imagines le mec
puisque vous avez trouvé des a forcé
interdits à la vente en plus sa moelle
de boeuf donc vous l'achetez en
contrebande chez buffalo bill
lacombe et où cette moelle de l'offre
d'achat c'est compliqué mais non passage
de l'âge de stries axa ah bon tu connais
déflorant vous l'avez sinon c'est pas
très apprêtée vous avez lavé natacha
mais c'est sûr que j'efface voir des
choses aujourd'hui et ça fait oui mais
c'est un bon truc et ça se voit avec la
moelle de boeuf qui veut faire des
cheveux comme ça elsa de nivelles grave
il va rentrer à la maison dire antoine
vain d'acheter de la moelle de boeuf
bien alors votre boutique natacha amal
est dû à un mélange détonnant votre père
est marocain et votre mère russe et
voilà c'est plus c'est encore plus
mélanger que ça ah bon qu'est-ce qui
ad'autres polonais quand c'est polonais
causé en plus ça fait un mélange génial
ben j'ai envie de chanter ensemble tous
pays arrête arrête alors vous avez une
enfance le chaotique à cause de ce entre
casablanca et à bruxelles encore depuis
l'antique mans oui ça a été assez encore
pire que ça oui on a été très très
ballotté ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez un énorme besoin d'amour mais comme
tout le monde comme tout le monde bien
sûr et bien en plus bon comme vous étiez
petit votre père qui était donc médecin
il s'intéressait qu'à vos notes
alors évidemment pour vous c'était
c'était un petit peu de terribles et
c'est vrai qu'il vous dénigrez votre
père quand j'étais petit oui ils vous
disaient comme ça t'es moche je n'ai pas
été élevé
dans le culte de ni eau ni de la beauté
ni l'intelligence enfin me concernant
mais bon je pense que ça partait d'un
bon sentiment mais j'ai quand même
grandi un petit peu dans le dégoût de
vous même d'une certaine façon non mais
c'est à dire que j'ai vraiment pris
conscience très très tard que je pouvais
que je pouvais m'améliorer quoi je
pouvais être plus que ce que ce qu'on me
disait quoi
alors quand vous étiez petit vous
vouliez faire ça comme métier oui
c'est vrai dans sa soeur j'étais gamine
annonce et c'est la première fois que
j'ai des contacts que j'ai vu et c'est
vrai que moi ça m'a enfin bon j'avais
j'avais vite en neuf ans à
m'impressionner à tel point je me suis
dit c'est ça que je veux faire je sais
pas pourquoi enfin je veux dire à mon
avis devait y avoir inconsciemment une
espèce de désir de sexuel comme je suis
heureusement oui heureusement
heureusement votre mère on arrive aux
choses sérieuses vous faisait lire des
pièces de théâtre et vous adoriez sa
natacha et vers 9 ans vous jouer molière
avec votre soeur qui vous donne la
réplique c'est déjà assez précoce mais
le déclic c'est un terminal donc au
lycée français de bruxelles
quand vous jouez le roi s'amuse pour un
spectacle de fin d'année et là vous
ressentez pour la première fois sous les
applaudissements du public
le frisson le grand frisson ben oui ça a
été une espèce de j'ai ressenti comme
une vague d'amour c'est extatique quand
ma tête
lorsque je vous propose quand même si
d'applaudir très très très fort natacha
pour qu'elle retrouve cette sensation
qu'elle a une
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter
je vous demande de vous arrêter merci
beaucoup avait donné la même impression
qu'au lycée français bruxelles être
idiot ça me fait plaisir
ah oui bien sûr voilà donc là vous
rentrez effectivement au conservatoire
d'art dramatique de bruxelles fait un
petit peu mannequin en même temps en or
à cette époque là j'étais mannequin
parallèlement parallèle vous ma façon de
gagner ma vie s'est étonné le jour vous
a proposé de mannequins parce que votre
père faisait tellement dit que je dis
est pas belle la vie mais comme on
voulait que shaw mannequin oui c'est
quelqu'un m'a abordé un vrai photographe
guy vasseur elle pas de voir l'amour de
mes jeux soir j'avais ma petite soeur
avec moi n'est pas seul à la première
serre voile alors très vite évidemment
vous passez au répertoire classique j'ai
réussi assez assez rapidement un sur
scène jouer molière beaumarchais
shakespeare
et puis vous jouez voilà oui racines
phèdre le jour le jour où les gens qui
font du casting pour moulins sont dans
la salle
rien à voir à quoi ça tient
vous auriez pu faire des classiques
toute votre vie rentré la comédie
française mais c'était vraiment le
chemin était tout tracé
les contrats s'enchaînaient avec une
espèce de phase ii logique comme ça
qu'ils qui était j'irai pas confortable
mais en tous les cas une espèce de
certitude que c'était mon chemin que
c'était ma voie et c'est vrai que je
pour moi ma famille ma maison c'était
les planches pas voilà donc vous devenez
célèbre natacha amal dans le rôle de
symbole
j'ai émis 1
moi je comprenais rien je crois que star
du porno dans le rôle de samantha donc
auprès du commissaire moulin
ça commence à marcher hélas la couille
c'est le cas de le dire échecs amoureux
cet été lille va vous plaquer tout
c'était un moment vous étiez mal non
sérieux genre la sdf vous habitiez un
peu partout chez les uns chez les autres
vous êtes parti à new york c'est pour
fuir c'était à ce point là il fallait
que vous fuyez l'europe à ce moment là
[Rires]
pour faire peau neuve
voilà et c'est vrai que je me suis
amusée comme une petite folle et ça m'a
récemment je fais oublier le mec ça
absolument
ouais et vous en êtes sortis grâce au
bouddhisme pour moi ça a été vraiment
plutôt une méthode une méthode de
reconstruction et et de maîtrise des
processus émotionnels négatif de 2 à
travers la méditation
je veux pas insister bien sûr mais je
veux dire pourquoi ça s'était mal passé
avec lui vous aviez été trop j'étais
mieux je m'intéresse à natacha non j'ai
juste le problème sexuel
attendez je vais poser la question
clairement
est ce que il vous avez quitté parce que
vous l'aviez tromper voir quand même
moyen
non je préfère dire les choses comme
elles savent que le bouddhisme samassa
mine est en cours
sérieusement ça est ce que c'est ça
est-ce que la faute venez de vous voilà
ce que je veux savoir
non mais c'est vrai qu'à une époque où
j'étais un petit peu allumeuse quoi
c'est vrai vous non natacha vais pas me
dire jean prix c'est donc la
prescription
je suis un peu allume vous étiez c'est
vous même qui le dit vous étiez une
séductrice invétéré et widgets trop de
témoins pour pouvoir le nier donc c'est
vrai que j'aime séduire voilà et là vous
êtes en train d'y arriver avec moi donc
voilà l'annoncé des résultats une
allumeuse n'ont allumé alors je pense
que c'est dû à la légère nuance est
différent et pas négligeable en ce qu
une allumeuse c'est quelqu'un qui peut
vraiment faire du mal je pense qu'une
séductrice ou quelqu'un qui séduit quand
tu joues bien
[Applaudissements]
donc aujourd'hui tout est réglé bien
alors faisait mine de vie se faire le
plus de bien possible mais sans jamais
faire de mal aux autres
c'est bien c'est très beau dit c'est
dans la ligne éditoriale de boulogne
c'est alors natacha entre un génie qui
baisent mal est un abruti qui baisent
bien elle choisit de génie qui baisent
mal est-ce que ça s'adresse à claude
cette phrase et non question de génie tu
fais mal
non mais par contre c'est une question
qui a été formulée donc c'est pas mal de
les former comme ça l'occasion mais mais
mais c'est vrai que la réponse oui
effectivement c'est celle là à savoir
que je préfère j'espère que voilà c'est
à dire que le la personne qui n'a pas la
cervelle mais alors est s'est très vite
lassant quoi voilà elle aime les abats
quoi la moelle et les biens alors vous
avez déclaré l'attaché à mal parfois
au quotidien ça me fait chier d'être
sexy merci un sacré jabba ouais faut
tout le temps ça prêter des animaux
c'est tout c'est très complet je vous en
prie les boeufs faut bien la moelle il
ne donne pas d'enseignement la moelle
ils viennent pas chez vous pour donner
la moelle et pour les tuer mais je n'ai
pas à l'abattoir non plus légers tranche
voire même de découvrir
alors ça vous embête marraine
d'exception et comprend rien
[Applaudissements]
ça vous fait chier du xive ou des
consommateurs traduit pour enfin en tous
les cas alors c'est ce qu'on va faire là
on va faire une interview si vous aviez
été moche
[Musique]
la voilà avance bien céline dion
[Applaudissements]
alors si vous aviez t'es moche natacha
est ce que vous auriez continuer vos
études
alors d'abord jeu d'abord j'ai envie de
dire que j'ai été moche je peux magnéto
serge messi a bon mais bien sûr parce
que être moche ou bosser dans la tête
oui et je mets j'étais moche d'ailleurs
j'ai eu vraiment la sensation profonde
de l'être quand j'étais gosse quand
j'étais adolescent j'étais sûr d'être
moche et d'ailleurs en photo ça se
voyait
si vous aviez été moche vous auriez fait
quels métiers intellectuels
ouais si vous aviez été moche est ce que
vous auriez fait de la politique
pourquoi pas oui si vous aviez des
moches est-ce que vous pensez que votre
mec aurait vu votre beauté intérieure
comme on dit ah mais je me serais
débrouiller pour qu'il la voit si vous
aviez été moche c'est ce que vous auriez
coucher le premier soir
si si c'est très chaud pourquoi pas même
sens est moche en même temps si vous
aviez été moche c'est ce que j'aurais
une chance avec vous si j'avais été
moche ouais
oui non je recommence
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant michel edouard
leclerc
il
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
comment ça va ça va très bien alors
michel edouard leclerc vous profitez du
festival de la bande dessinée
d'angoulême pour publier itinéraire dans
l'univers de la bande dessinée avec
chantal marie val chez flammarion
[Musique]
un travail colossal de décryptage
d'explication un livre somme une mine
pour les fous de bd rencontres avec les
plus grands alors je vais en citer
quelques-uns mais on arrive à 50 non oui
oui avait commencé j'en oublie il ya eu
des retards dit schwitten pétillant
moebius martin margerin l'oustal
jodorowsky geluck truilhé bout benoît
plein plein plein d'auteurs des jeunes
des vieux des humoristes et des sérieux
voilà expliquait qu'ils sont de quoi il
il s'inspire leur parcours leur
technique
c'est très complet j'ai pas voulu faire
un spa livres d'auteurs c'était plutôt
un livre pour présenter un petit peu la
richesse de ces artistes qu'on appelle
les artistes du 9e art souvent on dit
que la bande dessinée c'est un apéritif
avant le vrai archos qu'est la peinture
le cinéma mais moi j'ai voulu montrer
que qu'il y avait des vrais talents il y
avait des talents confirmés comme ceux
que vous avez cités comme tardy comme
bien sûr uderzo janet martin mais il y
avait plein de jeunes aussi qui
renouvelait les images le scénario et
voilà c'est un coup de coeur c'est une
passion c'est un livre plaisir je veux
faire partager sa vrai plus oui vraiment
vraiment alors le festival d'angoulême
est devenu le véritable effectivement
rendez-vous du 9e art comme vous dites
est là la ville entière vit à l'heure de
la baie des artistes éditeurs qui se
rend compte du monde entier et serra en
le festival a failli mourir en 1990
quand le maire d'angoulême boucheron
appuyé le parti avec la caisse
il partit en argentine avec la quête la
casse de la mairie ouais et le festival
avec des caisses vides et le nouveau
maire chavanel et mettre la clé sous la
porte quand vous avez décidé de voler au
secours du festival alors leclerc
sponsor du festival de la bd ça fait
hurler chez les ch et les soixante
huitards la bande de charlie hebdo les
légendes de fluide glacial tous à la
brèche était le représentant ou si ce
n'est du grand capital du moins des
temples provocateur de la société de
consommation ce pour contre lequel il
avait fait des sit in en 68 mais
finalement ils ont avalé quand même
leurs dessins et leur bulle parce que
bon le vrai on a fait des choses sympas
il ya wolinski qui vous a beaucoup aidés
ouais un vol à skis c'est un grand
monsieur mois ce qui a été le premier à
retourner sa veste
peut-être un réformiste avant leur aval
à un match épique
alors votre père un peu comme enrico
macias a eu droit aux honneurs de cinq
colonnes à la une à 59
dix ans après la la fondation de son
premier magasin le petit épicier de
landerneau est devenu une star nationale
en quelques minutes grâce comme toi
grâce à la à la télé votre père a
inventé la distribution moderne avec une
idée de génie c'est supprimer les
intermédiaires
oui parce que c'était quand même l'air
de la spéculation tout le monde tout le
monde d'en ramasser un maximum et
c'était une manière de de se battre
contre contre aussi des gens qui donnait
des leçons de morale mais qui vendaient
très cher il prenait sur les salariés
qui prenait 2 sur wii
enfin bon ceci étant ça change rien
parce que les consommateurs s'y
retrouvent parce que vous vendez moins
cher mais pour arriver à vendre moins
cher vous étrangler les producteurs ben
c'est ce qu'on dit parce que ça vient
pas ici je l'aimais avec surtout c'est
surtout ce que disent forcément ceux qui
vendent plus cher on dit pas d'un type
qui vend cher que c'est un mauvais type
forcément celui qui est alors moi j'ai
très peur un jour qu'on dise que je suis
un type bien que je suis paco boy je
suis pas marginal ça voudrait dire que
j'en ramasse ouais
jamais les gens ça fait cinquante les
gens qui vous vendent ou se plaignent
mais tout le temps d'abord entre nous
ils ont raison c'est celui qui vend
essaye de vendre plus cher et nous on
essaie de vendre moins cher mais c'est
une contradiction c'est un conflit c'est
une guerre
quelqu'un qui veut vendre par exemple
des pommes de terre chez vous 10 tonnes
de pommes de terre par an s'il veut
vendus chez vous d'une année sur l'autre
ils doivent ou rétrocéder 35% du prix
nobel de terre dont il faut pas
reprendre non non non un faux pas
reprendre la fnsea qui disent j'ai
souvent tes la fnsea son rôle c'est de
chercher l'affrontement s'est bagarré
chercher une pensée positive de la fnsea
sur la distribution et je vous sacrerait
ouais un bon chercheur ouais non c'est
normal on est en cours depuis permanent
attendait ça fait cinquante ans que
quand on essaie de faire baisser les
prix
mon père a commencé j'essaie de
continuer évidemment c'est d'un côté le
peuple de salariés applaudi de l'autre
côté ceux qui voudraient faire des
marges écrit c'est la règle du je pense
pas qu'à excusez moi mais enfin je pense
pas que les producteurs de pommes de
terre espère faire des marges énormes et
ce qu'ils veulent c'est bouffer les mecs
oui mais ça je les comprends très
méchant je conçois aussi très bien
qu'être producteurs aujourd'hui dans un
marché qui est très guerrier qui est
très difficile avec la grande europe
avec la mondialisation c'est pour des
gens qui sont pas formés justement à ce
type de conflit c'est vachement dur et
c'est là où il ya des mesures à prendre
l'état pourrait intervenir sa pensée que
l'état va financer des producteurs dont
on vend moins cher non mais par exemple
moi je trouve ça par exemple pour
prendre l'exemple des pommes de terre je
trouve ça complètement qu'à un moment
donné c'est pas parce qu on baissera le
prix de la pomme de terre qu on en
vendra plus il ya des moments aussi des
types n'ont plus de revenus en vendant
des pommes de terre il faut que l'état
intervienne et disent ok on met un prix
minimum de même qu'on a fait un smic
pour l'épauler salariés moi ça me
choquera mais aujourd'hui l'état sous
prétexte de l'idéologie laisse
s'affronter les uns les autres et nous
demande de faire une journée
vous voulez que ce soit l'état qui fixe
le prix des pommes de terre moi je suis
libéral jusqu'à libéral sauf quand ça
oui mais moi je suis là un libéral en
politique
ouais je suis pour le marché mais à un
moment donné je crois que le politique
doit prendre une responsabilité sociale
mais quand vous voyez les paysans qui
viennent sur les parkings de vos
magasins vidés leur pomme de terre met
le feu à ce qu'ils ont à l'epo parce
qu'ils crèvent de faim les mecs
travaillent jour et nuit n'ont pas de
vacances ça vous le savez et ça vous
fait rien à tcc mais moi je vais
justement moi je suis faudrait que
l'état leur donne du pognon non mais je
voudrais que l'état qui m'impose des
règles de concurrence disent qu'à un
moment donné pour c'est pour ces
artisans pour ce jeudi pas pour ces gens
là pour les chefs d'entreprise eh bien
il faut qu'on change la règle du jeu
c'est pareil dans le on va pas laisser
des cent des salaires n'importe comment
sous prétexte qu'ils à l'amendé de
mondialisation serait techniques et les
concurrents on fixe un minimum mais ça
c'est à l'état de le dire c'est pas à
michel edouard leclerc pas plus qu'à
thierry ardisson non et puis alors
surtout pas c'est toujours pareil en
france allez les petits cachent les gros
parce qu'évidemment on vous met toujours
le petit pont peace de vent qui va
crever de faim et agriculteurs en fait
il y en a d'autres qui s'en mettent
plein les poches des deux côtés faut pas
se tromper de combat
ouais
aider les petits oui ok mais derrière
les petits il faut pas que les gros
continuent à se mettre dans les poches
enfin un kilo de fruits par exemple
grâce à vos convainc pas si si si je
vous en coûte 20 kg de fruits qui vaut 3
euros ouais y'a combien pour le
producteur
oh il ya peut-être un euro ouais il 10
07 et quand
oui mais oui bon d'accord ça dépend quel
fruit oui non mais si vous voulez une
réponse car et c'est évident aujourd'hui
que c'est plus dur d'être producteur et
de dépendre du marché donc des
distributeurs que d'être distributeurs
serre si vous vendez pas votre pomme de
terre moment deux autres choses c'est
évident que c'est plus dur d'être
producteur ne donne pas envie d'acheter
le livre je vais le voir arriver comme
mandat je me méfierais de l'est parce
qu'il est bon il est bon il pourra jouer
et en banlieue ça se passe comment c'est
vrai qu'à cause des mesures de sécurité
vous êtes obligé de vendre plus cher en
banlieue ce qui fait que finalement vous
vendez plus cher aux pauvres cloches
ben oui ça ça fait partie des
contradictions c'est qu'on nous demande
de rester de faire du social de rester
en banlieue c'est à dire que les
magasins pour les riches on les envoie
dans les centre-villes deauville ou
ailleurs et les magasins argenteuil à
sarcelles c'est assez pour nous
simplement comme l'état s'est fait la
malle comme il ya les commissariats si
vide
il faut prendre des billets vous savez
pas qui sont dans les société de vigiles
non plus il n'ya pas d'agrément ça coûte
cher et évidemment on fait payer plus
cher des comptes d'exploitation à des
gens qui mériteraient qu'on leur vende
moins cher donc c'est pas bien bien là
comme vous travaillez en banlieue aussi
on va vous faire une interview caillera
en dix mois
ça va bien ou quoi ça va bien tu es venu
seul où il ya du demain avec what
moi je parle que le breton de ce type
peut y aller comme ça c'est pas loin
tu es venu tout seul où il ya du 2 -
avec what
je comprends rien tu comprends ce toit
du monde avec toi
bravo bien alors je suis incapable
t'as quoi comme tu revois une zone euro
ouais ça va non un euro non dit on vient
vous avez des raids moi quoi et et dis
moi tu aimes les meufs avec des gros de
shoot à la fin j'ai compris tout de
suite ça un nom des petits des petits
d'accord c'est quoi ton plus grosse vie
tant que plus grand venir chez toi
d'accueil dis moi tu crois qu'il ya plus
de tarbes à droite ou à gauche
à mon avis tous pourris prévu répondent
bien là me cache cache et où il doit y
en avoir un peu quelque part parce qu'il
paraît qu'on a des balances de peser
extrêmement précises éclectique viennent
par l'étoile savoir si toi tu y avait
chez eux j'ai compris si on avait chez
moi non
alors vas-y là me k way to yade j'achète
tout j'ai touché à laquelle je manquais
il est en train de nous expliquer que
les 10 heures déjà mais jamais cieux
mais gentil viennent peser le shit chez
leclerc c'est un scoop
parce que c'est le seul message de leur
jus cressat dix mois déjà bien filmé un
petit baie de hawke en même temps et non
je suis et je ne peux pas supporter la
fumée ouais ben bella je peux pas
supporter la lame et fut l'âme et fut
way ton dernier grand kiff dans la vie
c'était quoi
alors tant d années grand kiff c'était
quoi bon dernier
qu'est ce qui vous a excité la dernière
fois au mieux aux joueurs et les a mis
en joie
tout à l'heure la balade dure je
trouvais ça très marin ouais ouais ouais
il surnomme commenté homeboy junior
parce que landerneau dallas au reste
tout est du genre à kerra pour tout le
monde ou c'est chacun pour sa gueule
j'ai compris tu t'en fais pas une salle
56 alors
chacun dans sa loge après c'est moi qui
passe à la casse et m'attaque à toi
c'est normal c'est quoi la dernière fois
tu t'es friter avec un câble avec un
ticket mec producteurs non c'est dieu
vous les étrangler jamais chien d'où je
donc je suis un axe sud
non non je vais vous laisser filer donc
si jamais j'en fais un bon joueur à qui
va faire des photos de boules j'ai fait
plus de fautes
je remercie ma balle a vite on espère
beaucoup du temps d'envoyer je
t'embrasse qu'elle repart en espagne
mais je reviens le 2 février alors ça
c'est mon choix
ah ouais ouais avec kevin thomas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille nathan jacno
[Musique]
6 mai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
ce qui fait fluide donc yakine j'imagine
que c'est c'est vous qui me jugent
cadillac cki cadillac et cadillac c'est
lui et max à l'om si sale aux jeunes
qu'elle apparemment séduit voix la voix
ils sont très bien que nouvelle recrue
fameux nouvelles recrues tableaux d'art
disque a pas du tout d'abord j'ai donné
ma bénédiction hills écarté par un dû
oui j'ai dit c'est très bien bah moi je
n'ai rien à voir
après que j'arrive des bêtes des animaux
quel bon lorsqu'il font ils ont un tube
qui marche très très bien
qu'ils s'appellent je suis plus cheap à
fénelon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donne pas
[Musique]
voilà ça commence comme ça si je suis
plus de shit alors on se dit ça y est on
est revenue en 77 à l'époque où j'étais
un gars de fumer des pétards ont dit ça
y est c'est les fans qui reviennent mais
à un moment la chanson repart et ça
s'appelle jure fume du shit de vichy
j'ai eu deux conversations
[Musique]
puis tout seul dans mon coin
on regarde à quoi ça ressemble jeune
magnéto serge football
il est grassement interminable
oui et je me trouve plus beaux unis les
yeux rouges le thème pas la parano
je vous
[Musique]
et
je
voilà stupeflip bullshit ouais
j'accueille isabelle boulay non alors
stupeflip comme vous réinventer votre
légende à chaque interview j'ai pas
préparé deux fiches parce que de toute
façon j'allais bien raison mon petit
canard a inventé une connerie
différentes ont fait l'interview pas
préparé oui bon ben voilà c'est
l'interview pas préparé comment ça va
pippa brown et ouais pourquoi parce que
rien ah ouais d'accord dont vous êtes
les nouveaux bâtard du showbiz c'est ça
didon peu de respect non mais c'est un
sergent oui bah si tu veux aller 5500m
vous voulez où vous venez d'où là tu
viens d'où toi dirais que je viens de
calviac voyage près de bordeaux en
dordogne ouais ouais
célèbre pour son nazis flamands m6 m6 à
l'eau il vient d'évoluer nous loue m6 à
l'eau il vient du mans je viens du mans
et toi tu viens d'où king ju et bien de
paris ouais ouais c'est votre parrain
jacques neau c'est votre parent c'est
votre marraine vous connaissez ce qu'il
a fait jacno com - ouais ouais ouais
c'est génial
[Musique]
d
cet état
donc c'est vrai que c'était assez proche
de ce qu'ils font je comprend une
filiation bon n'ai aucun rapport avec
ces jacquard sur son prochain album donc
maintenant tu as essayé
art mengo marque et steve kent
la prochaine fois si stupeflip
exactement c'est vraiment stupéfiant
ouais c'est déjà des chansons regarde la
chanson c'est bien mais mais
c'est le point de vue me musique est
vite mais c'est beau ça me rappelle un
peu gainsbourg william hague à merveille
pour les yeux mais je préfère gainsbourg
ouais
comment est ce que je pensais que
c'était battu clique qui casserait alors
cédric aussi c'est trop dur d'un organe
qui fait du théâtre et tout ça c'est
enrique au kursaal et gauchy
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant à l'écran
il
merrigan bonsoir au soir donc vous êtes
grand reporter spécialiste de politique
étrangère auteurs de deux best-sellers
la guerre du golfe le dossier secret
avec pierre salinger est tempête du
désert et vous publiez un livre qui est
déjà un best-seller qui rentrait
directement je crois cinquième dans la
liste de l'express qui s'appelle la
guerre des bouches les secrets
inavouables
[Applaudissements]
vous allez voir c'est énorme c'est un
livre qui est consacré à la famille bush
et on commence avec le grand père bush
prescott bush prescott bush vous
expliquer dans votre bouquin comment il
a fait fortune pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale grâce aux nazis à
travers deux sociétés l'une young
banking corporation et la cie les hyènes
american corporation et cette deuxième
société avait des mines de charbon et de
zinc en pologne en allemagne et ses
mines étaient exploités en partie par
des prisonniers des camps absolument
prescott bush a été en effet donc un
homme qui a fait toute sa carrière en
achetant des entreprises durant la
deuxième guerre mondiale les entreprises
nazis et il y avait un personnage qu'il
est très proche de lui et qui était
thyssen 600t effet carrément le banquier
privé d'hitler il avait d'ailleurs
publié une biographie qui s'appelait
comment j'ai financé hitler
depuis 1923 donc voila et là la fortune
des bouchers la dynastie des bush s'est
établi à partir en effet de la
trajectoire de ce personnage qui est
devenu ensuite extrêmement respectable a
autorité et à l'intérieur des
établissements américains
voilà donc premières révélations livre
d'eric laurent le grand père de george w
bush faisait tout à fait officiellement
y siéger au comité de direction de la
cie les jeunes banking corporation
bilodeau les 10 c'est justement ce que
pierre tout allait il y avait deux types
d'activités à l'époque il y avait parmi
les sympathisants à une sympathisant
nazi y avait des kennedy qui affiche
effectivement comme joe kennedy opinion
ouvertement propres pro nazis mais
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas avec
l'allemagne et il y avait prescott bush
qui lui commercer avec l'allemagne et
les activités étaient suffisamment
répréhensible pour qu'en 1942 le
gouvernement de roosevelt victimes au
nom de
l'inculpé pour collaboration avec
l'ennemi donc c'est un revenant de
l'ennemi actrice qu'on appelait les
miracles il est des entreprises
d'ailleurs des bouchons ont été saisis
par les autorités fédérales américaines
voilà premier scoop du bouquin et
réclamant serré ce rêveur non non non on
passe on passe aux pères ainsi on a vu
le grand père donc on passe au père l'ex
président george bush donc lui il a été
nommé en fait à la cia un moment pour
camoufler l'existence d'une d'une agence
qui s'appelle et nsa national security
agency et 7 7 agences contrairement au
fbi ou un seuil à nana été créée par
aucune loi en fait oui la nsf est une
agence qui peut mettre sur écoute le
monde entier si vous décrochez votre
téléphone aux états unis compris dans
une cabine téléphonique
vous êtes sur écoute donc il ya des
centres des coudes à travers le monde
entier il ya des relais tous les
satellites en effet donc qui servent à
transmettre les communications sont
placées sur écoute par la reine et c est
en effet george bush avait été chargé de
à la tête de la cia de camoufler les
activités qui étaient à l'époque comme
vous le disiez extrêmement vraiment
douteuses opaque de l'année c'est qui
n'a it qui a été créée en 1947 par un
acte spécial de l'administration truman
qui n'a jamais été rendue publique en
syrie et du budget en série et des
hommes
voilà c'est ce qu'on voit en général
d'air dans les films de science fiction
c'est à dire une une agence qui est
répertorié nulle part qui n'existe pas
mais qui en fait existe bien puisque
après le fbi et la cia
c'est la troisième voie là alors le père
bush donc de georges bush lui il a un
ami qui s'appelle jim baffes et ce jim
basse l'a beaucoup soutenu
c'est un vrai ami l'a beaucoup soutenu
pendant pendant ses campagnes et il est
associé se dit mme baffe à un dénommé
khalid bin mahfouz qui le patron de la
bci alors c'est quoi la bcc c'est une
banque qui a été créé par deux
personnage c'est étonnant deux
pakistanais qui voulait créer un grand
établissement bancaire qui pourrait
faire contrepoids aux grandes banques
occidentales et qui pourrait ainsi donc
investir à travers les pays du
tiers-monde c'était une entreprise
extraordinaire loi bien très simplement
il s'est avéré que la bcc y était la
plus grande organisation criminelle
qu'on n'ait jamais créé il y avait à
l'intérieur de la bci tous les comptes
en effet donc soit la mafia italienne
soit en effet par exemple des barons de
la drogue du cartel de medellin est
comme ça le roi de la drogue et trafic
d'opium d'un triangle d'auray n'ont rien
gare par exemple plus en effet je passe
sur abou nidal et quelques autres
terroristes qui avaient des comptes
réguliers voilà alors la baisse et s'est
hissé de cette banque donc donc vous
parler ou les saoudiens transférer leur
argent pour ben laden et pour al qaïda
et je rappelle que cette baie cci et est
possédé par khalid bin mahfouz qui est
un ami de jim basse qui lui même est un
grand ami de george bush
exactement il vous soyez en plus que
monsieur khalid bin mahfouz que vous
évoquez qu'est le plus gros bang et
d'arabie saoudite est également le beau
frère d'oussama ben laden
oui c'est ça c'est très bien portants
voilà exactement la soeur a épousé ben
laden voilà alors ce bin mahfouz
il a aidé bouche aussi un trait
directement cette fois non pas par
l'intermédiaire de jean bart mais il a
été très directement la famille bush
dans une compagnie pétrolière qu'il
possède qui s'appelle arquennes il les a
aidés pour obtenir des facilités avec
certains émirats du golfe un oui parce
que effectivement jim basse donc était
un ami docile et george deubeuliou bush
l'actuel président il l'avait rencontrée
lorsqu'il a fait son service militaire
ensemble la garde nationale du texas et
donc à chaque fois au cours de la
carrière de bush l'actuel président
chaque fois qu en effet il connaîtra des
revers ils seront nombreux puisque en
effet on sera dans le pétrole et à
chaque fois avec un succès croissant
à chaque fois il sera renflouée par
exemple est très riche même d'un vert le
petit bouchon c'est pas un homme
d'affaires véritablement et donc à
chaque fois il sera renflouée par un
certain nombre d' effectivement d'amis
très cher d'onde bin mahfouz et dont ben
laden parce que ce jim basse aussi
parallèlement et car cette élite immense
et un point tournant ce jim base de vie
à partir de 1976 peu appel rachat de ces
compagnies l'homme d'affaires des ben
laden au texas
et vous savez qu'elle va être une des
premières actions en effet les ben laden
ça va être le rachat de l'aéroport de
houston au texas
alors pendant toutes les années 80 donc
avant la première guerre du golfe il ya
de très bonnes relations entre les usa
et l'irak les américains financés et arm
saddam hussein pour l'aider à gagner sa
guerre contre l'iran un petit peu comme
ils ont soutenu d'ailleurs ben laden
pour lutter contre les soviétiques en
afghanistan c'est un petit peu le même
genre de méthode
1 et alors la cia aide les irakiens à
bien utiliser le gaz moutarde faire ce
gaz moutarde qu'il cherche la mort en
irak en fait c'est les américains qui
leur ont vendus mais non seulement ils
auront vendues et la cia leur a appris
comment s'en servir contre les iraniens
oui c'est ça ll effectivement les
irakiens calibrer leurs attaques et leur
taille contre les troupes iraniennes au
gaz moutarde en effet bien sûr non
seulement ça mais par exemple les
hélicoptères a fourni par exemple qu'un
à usage théoriquement civile un servent
à saddam hussein a bombardé d alarme
chimique le fameux village de la bahia
qui kurdistan au kurdistan cher que le
kurdistan et c'est très grave le
kurdistan était bombardé par des
hélicoptères bell qui ont été vendus par
les américains défensive il est utilisé
par saddam hussein à des fins de
génocide
enfin tout simplement dur je bouge ira
très loin puisque malgré l'opposition en
effet donc d'une partie de son
administration il continuera à financer
saddam hussein il continuera à l'armée
jusqu'au premières semaines de la crise
du golfe oui parce qu'il militait bouche
militer pour qu'on donne des centaines
de millions de dollars 2 milliards de
l'arrivée
luis amado à un milliard de dollars tout
ça par des circuits qui sont absolument
officieux et les circuits qui sont même
illégaux puisque ça ne transitera par
une banque italienne installée
effectivement dans l'état de géorgie à
atlanta sellaband zanella vauxrot donc
la banque du travail italienne qui est
une banque dans le détail mais il ya
beaucoup beaucoup mieux d'en haut niveau
du civisme par exemple parce que bush
père a la haute main sur le dossier
irakien océane ministration egan est un
nom donné en 1983 on décide d'envoyer un
émissaire spécial auprès de saddam
hussein oui voilà et donc on en voit un
homme qui va rencontrer saddam hussein
qui s'entendra merveilleusement bien
réduit qui revient washington fait un
rapport mais alors dithyrambique sur
saddam hussein sur son régime
en décidant qu'il faut le soutenir
l'armée le finance et de renforcer et
vous savez qui c'est donald rumsfeld
exactement le ministre de la défense
américain celui qui est aujourd'hui le
faucon des faucons et qui explique
aujourd'hui l'irak une d'engins québec
la fonctionnelle magne sur la vieille
europe
exactement on continue donc on passe à
bush junior dont george w bush alors lui
il est très lié à un fonds
d'investissement qui s'appelle carlyle 1
c'est une firme d'investissement privée
et où le père travaille pour carla elle
lui les traits en osmose avec carlyle et
carlyle a passé un contrat avec le
pentagone de 12 milliards de dollars
contre l'avis des experts du pentagone
donc à la famille bush profite de sa
position et tour favoriser un fonds
d'investissement auxquels ils sont liés
d'une année carnaille est un organisme
d'une puissance considérable est un
fonds d'investissement probablement le
premier des états unis
là des actifs de 16 milliards de
donneurs se font au travail dans
l'industrie d'armement donc il est
considéré comme le 11e fabricant
d'armement des états unis par exemple
à l'heure actuelle les chars bradley les
chars lourds qui sont massés dans la
région du golfe et qui sont prêts à
foncer sur l'irak sont fabriqués par
d'une des entreprises contrôlées par
carlyle les missiles des missiles
pointés à bord des navires américains
dans la zone du golfe est prêt a
effectivement être tiré sur l'irak sont
également fabriquées par une des
filiales le quart lie aujourd'hui le
dire on est dans une situation qui est
au delà du délit d'initié
c'est à dire que le père bush george
bush père donc est un des dirigeants de
ce fonds d'investissement carlyle qui
négociaient que le pentagone
donc avec une administration dirigée par
son fils et qui donc bénéficient des
choix faits par son fils on peut
supposer qu à terme non seulement
évidemment monsieur bush père s'enrichit
mais à la limite lorsqu'il aura quitté
la présidence de george bush junior
bénéficiera évidemment des choix et des
investissements qui ont été faits par
son père simulait une situation
scabreuse c'était assez scabreux et
règlement est ce que c'est vrai que ben
laden a été par bancs interposés un
actionnaire de carlyle ben laden les
peines laden la famille ben natalia
l'énorme actionnaires de carlyle
il faut souligner qu' on ne peut pas et
c'est ça qui est fascinant est très
troublant on ne peut pas dissocier les
bouches des ben laden cuire pendant 25
ans alors j'ai bien admet qu'il existe
des relations d'affaires
mais je veux dire qu'on sauve quelqu'un
par exemple de la faillite à plusieurs
reprises comme c'était le cas pour
charge de beignon bougez vous évoquez
tout à l'heure à arquennes la compagnie
pétrolière un art ken bogard kane a
comme dirigeante george deubeuliou bouge
ugo monye pétrolières qui ne réussit pas
effectivement obtenir des résultats est
abandonné elle va être mise en faillite
et sauvé de la faillite par ce banquier
saoudien pour évoquer avec l'aide des
ben laden et donc on va trouver 25
millions de dollars qui vont provenir
notamment pour une part de la bci et
pour une autre partie de l'union des
banques suisses
mais quand il ya le 11 septembre ben
laden se retire du fonds carlyle non ben
laden se retire pas de lait ben laden
renier les vallées et les ben laden
officiellement ont désavoué oussama ben
laden il faut le dire non il faut être
très clair
il a donc lui aussi il a perdu 1 a
souhaité saoudien depuis 94
mais il faudra attendre octobre ou
novembre pour que timidement à 32 lignes
on annonce que les les ben laden se
retire du fonds carlyle mais tous les
experts estiment que c'est complètement
faux et que donc on a modifié
effectivement la présentation mais qui
sont toujours présents à l'intérieur de
ce foncier qui vont bénéficier
évidemment de l'effort d'armement et de
la guerre qui probablement aura lieu
vous voulez prouver quoi que les
américains sont responsables de tout ce
qui se passe même avant l'attentât du 11
septembre n'est pas bon mais nous non
mais c'est à nos mini économie
strictement rien à la façon dont vous
raconter tout si tous ces faits non on
risque de comprendre que tout retombe
sur la tête des américains et que c'est
normal ce qui arrive quoi on veut non
les choses ont traîné dans les
chaussures tout à fait différent de
l'attentât du 11 septembre est une clé
pour comprendre la politique américaine
actuelle c'est vrai qu'en effet il ya en
effet à ce moment là sentiment d'une
formidable fragilité et la nécessité de
mener une grande lutte contre le
terrorisme
on est le 11 septembre cinq jours plus
tard déjà il ya une inflexion majeure au
sein de miss pression américaine c'est à
dire qu'il va y avoir une réunion qui va
être déterminante à camp david qui est
la résidence d'été des présidents et l'a
donc bouche réuni ses principaux
collaborateurs et il ya notamment un
homme qui va s'avérer déterminant pour
l'évolution des choses et notamment les
grandes orientations et choix de
politique étrangère américain cet homme
s'appelle paul vol sous vide c'est
astana c'est un faucon
c'est un faucon mais c'est un homme
aussi que d'un intellectuel qui est en
effet donc l'ancien doyen de
l'université de princeton et d'autre il
ya une discussion et alors on dit il
faut évidemment frappé l'afghanistan
bien entendu tout moi est d'accord mais
là où il faut vite intervient et dit
écoutez si on frappe en effet des
réseaux terroristes comme al qaïda et
ben laden sans frapper
déjà des pays capables de produire des
armes de destruction massive on est à
côté complètement de la plaque
là on se trompe il faut frapper les deux
il faut frapper les deux et 10 au
premier rang desquels il ya l'irak et la
discussion qu'ils s'engagent powell 10
mai l'irak n'est pas impliqué au le faux
vis dit quand on dit pas encore l'irak
ça veut dire jamais l'irak
il faut absolument en effet donc frappé
bagdad et à ce moment là
bush qui est tout de même jeu qui n'a
qui n'a pas une grande expérience de
politique étrangère élevé et donc est
assez fasciné par la démonstration de
vol fujitsu parce que vos solides du
10au si vous êtes un moment historique
au moment où l'amérique non qui est
délivrée en effet de cette rivalité
est-ouest a les mains libres et va
pouvoir en effet remodelé probablement
le reste du monde et notamment par
exemple le monde arabe qui est une zone
grande instabilité et bien nous pouvons
par exemple appliquer que les schémas de
la démocratie américaine
les imposé à l'irak et là nous aurons
une formidable vitrine démocratique qui
évidemment suscitera un grand effet de
contagion
alors donc évidemment b bush est
subjuguée et donc quand il revient à
washington doit la maison blanche deux
jours plus tard il dit notamment un de
ses proches collaborateurs
condoleezza rice à la wii et qui lui dit
écoutez on va commencer par
l'afghanistan mais l'irak et sur mon
agenda est en effet je suis persuadé que
saddam hussein est dans le coup
cependant à ce que à ce que dit quand
même un abricot c'est que pendant que
les éric leurent fait cette enquête sur
bush les américains rappellent les liens
que la france avait avec l'irak
on leur a vendu des avions leur
programme nucléaire on a dû y mettre un
toit aux irak
et puis les liens politiques pas
simplement chevènement mais mme sheeran
a présenté dans le moi ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est ce n'est pas tellement
d'attribuer jeu souvent le risque c'est
d'attributs le cynisme aux américains
c'est la ram c'est la fin du cynisme
politique ou plus d'électeurs ans c'est
la démonstration du cynisme politique
mais on peut pas s'en exonérer non plus
quoi c'est ça que peut pas tout mettre
sur les américains d'anti jeu puis me
permettre un terme formidable de notre
président jacques chirac qui quand il
était premier ministre je sais plus qui
peut-être de giscard sûrement à
si de saddam hussein que c'était le 2
grohl du moyen-orient alors c'est quand
même extraordinaire bien merci merci
beaucoup votre bouquin donc s'appelle la
guerre des bouches les secrets
inavouables d'un conflit
c'est chez plon merci avec
[Applaudissements]
vous avez toutes ces informations
washington
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu le veux ouais c'est la soirée
inquiétante enrico là après mohamed
sifaoui eric laurent la non mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai ça fait peur d'entendre
des choses comme ça mais moi je suis pas
étonné par les paradoxes et les
contrastes et les méandres de la
politique sur le dos des peuples les
combines les c'est vrai je suis pas
étonné je suis pages quand même pas
étonné tout pour l'argent pour l'intérêt
pour pendant ce temps là il y en a qui
travaillent les pauvres il lève à 7h du
matin et producteurs de pommes de terre
voilà il travaille puis savent pas tous
qui se manigance 1 au plus haut niveau
et maintenant
ouais
j'accueille patricia petibon
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
patricia petibon qui est sans doute la
plus jolie cantatrice du monde je crois
qu'on peut le dire
j'en ai jamais vu une plus jolie moi ces
gens vous êtes soprano colorature ce qui
veut dire vous avez une voix très
acrobatique cessa pyrotechniques
ouais avec beaucoup d guy beaucoup
d'écuries voilà comme un funambule sur
son fil
vous êtes connu pas du très grand public
mais enfin quand même vous avez été
récompensé en 2001 par une victoire de
la musique quand même c'est bien
magnéto les nommés sont roberto alagna
[Musique]
angela gheorghiu patricia petibon
le lauréat et patricia petibon patricia
petibon teinte retient
[Musique]
je suis très ému de recevoir ce prix
patricia petibon
alors avec serrar conçoit des
cantatrices dans cette émission n'ont
pas ravalement mais on est ravi
alors on peut vous écouter sur un disque
qui s'appelle les airs baroques français
chez virgin classique avec vos
accompagnateurs habituel dans ce genre
de registre les folies françoises 1
[Musique]
patricia petibon les airs baroques
français
[Applaudissements]
ce qui a changé c'est que vous avez
aussi enregistrer un disque avec les
mecs du secteur a qui sont quand même
des rappeurs à ccr est ce que ça marche
pourquoi partie sans qu'on sache
pourquoi mettez toujours là j'ai plus au
cimetière je tremblerai moi qui suis si
fier j'ai donc décidé que j'ai pris
dieu bénisse versailles ne renaît comme
le phénix gameplay de descendre l'autre
j'aurais voulu décent
chez que le fait de voir mourir
m'empêcherait pas suffire voilà c'est
cyril et roland donc tu cambon
maintenant ce qu'ils disent là y'a pas
de soucis elsa peut-être à dire voilà
carrière assez étonnante puisque vous
passez donc du secteur à comment bien de
l'entendre patricia à garnier puisque à
la rentrée de septembre vous allez faire
les indes galantes à garnier c'est ça
oui une reprise des indes galantes de
rameau toujours c'est une musique
absolument incroyablement fins moderne
avec comment dire des des tableaux enfin
un tableau sur évidemment sur tout ce
qui est très exotique et donc sur un
tableau sur les sauvages vous serez une
indienne
c'est très très drôle comme ça va être
terrible parce que des fois quand ce
n'est pas un opéra c'est dur coup à
trois quatre heures donc oui ce qui est
très difficile en fait il ya diverses
difficultés c'est à dire qu'il ya des
rôles qui sont longs il ya des rôles qui
sont courts et
et ce qui est difficile c'est qu'il faut
être toujours être là au moment même si
ces trois minutes
ouais on doit pas être à côté on doit
pas se dédoubler c'est ça qui est
difficile dans dans le champ enfin dans
tout art quoi il faut il faut être
entier au moment où on entre en scène
quand vous rentrez si tu vas avoir sur
les épaules une responsabilité énorme
ce qui est dur en fait c'est avant c'est
là où on doute beaucoup on ne sait plus
qui on est finalement puis finalement
passe le pas et on se transforme en une
créature qui n'a rien avoir avec soi
même c'est assez curieux
alors vous dites quand je reviens de
tourner je reviens en rampant et crever
voix oui c'est ça dans l'appartement le
canapé dans le couloir n'ont cessé
évidemment ça ça nous vide on donne
beaucoup au public c'est vrai que de se
retrouver en face d'un public sait c'est
quand même des fois 5000 personnes
on reçoit toute cette énergie puis il
faut il faut transmettre quelque chose
donc
alors ce don vient de quelque part parce
que bon vous venez de montargis je crois
quoi votre père était quoi prof à
montargis et ça donc au départ il n'est
pas une vraie prédestination 1
mais quand même votre mère
c'est jouer du piano sans avoir jamais
appris donc ça c'est assez
un indice quand même oui c'est une
famille qui aimait la musique qui qui
aimait les belles voix qui met l'art
familles modestes mais qui savait
apprécier les belles choses vous avez un
ancêtre qu'elle chantait comment ils
savent allier finances m
alors quand vous étiez quand vous étiez
enfant vous n'aviez pas le droit de
chanter dans la maison parce qu'elle
chantait toujours si j'avais le droit
enfin quand vous avez comme moi c'est à
dire qu'ils n'entendaient pas donc pas
les pauvres voisins
mais bon à table et puis un jour dont
vous avez une révélation c'est à toulon
vous allez voir l'auberge du cheval
blanc quand on n'a jamais mis les pieds
dans des lieux pareil on bon évidemment
la première fois c'est un choc
et puis bon pain non ça m'a plu samassa
m'a marqué mais j'ai pas j'ai pas
vraiment programmé un des deux
chanteuses ouais c'est la vie qui vous
mènera peut-être là où vous devez allez
vous fait chier que jennifer soit plus
connectez vous je dois dire que si si
j'ai choisi de faire de la musique c'est
surtout pas pour être connu ça n'a
jamais été mon but je crois que c'est le
principal en fait tu pourras pour
atteindre ses objectifs
et pour rester entier mais moi je
n'entends mieux si elle est connue c'est
c'est très bien c'est ainsi qu un
formidable non oui mais ce soir elle va
être super connue ouais
[Applaudissements]
bon je les adore
ah oui tiens au hasard voilà on voulait
rester avec nous donc pour le blind test
on va voir ce que vous allez donner un
quoi on ayez pas peur j'ai toujours par
à bon alors ce soir un blindtest météo
oblige spéciale de la chine aux platines
j'appelle masia philippe cordier
m
les bonnes
[Musique]
estac apple
également
mais
ressembler
mais voilà je rappelle ce qu mais flip
[Musique]
l'homme était un malade et javel max 1
x max qui anime sur fun radio avec
mélanie la radio libre du lundi au
vendredi de 21h à zéro heure
bonsoir ça va super bon vous connaissez
le principe 1 il ya l'équipe de
stupeflip pour maintenir l'équipe de
natacha amal galla l'équipe de natacha l
équipe ternois voilà vous savez comment
ça se passe je veux l'inter pas atteint
on est bien d'accord enrico on est prêt
didier wacogne
attention vous êtes très finit pas je
suis prêt
on va voir si ma fille est plus fort que
moustiques ah ouais un moustique il a
scotché tout le monde fait attention fil
de l'histoire
je prends ma rage et l'orgueil de vtt
boloni de la tâche à un point pour les
guides d'achat attention tu es prêt tout
doux béthune
[Musique]
montella dans un petit village cash
fleuve sauvage sur le
pardon non dario moreno bien sûr
aujourd'hui
attention attention attention vous êtes
prêts
mosca
[Musique]
oh
l'un d'eux lui une sirène
restera
le score à 2 pour natacha amal 1 pour
l'équipe 2 a très bien tension est
encore flou
[Musique]
bino
effectivement dans le nord
olga fille n'a pas perdu à manger bien à
tomber dans la dimension là ça vient de
nice joue weesp aux jo ça devient un peu
plus compliqué
[Musique]
superbe drop et vous racontez votre père
barrot yahoo
mais partir
ces salaires dus au non c'est sérieux
c'est sage et un job him huy jadis à
attendez attendez attendez que je
cherche du regard
non
et non la croire mais en voyant ce film
m'a dit elle n'a pas dit à la presse que
c'est ce que vous avez dit exactement
obtenu un score de 6 à 10 mois j'ai dit
comme jamais
[Applaudissements]
quatre fois
m
bordel
[Musique]
rita
là
sow et hazard
[Musique]
oui je sais pas
le souk
aurelio à web
mais jacques saint jacques
j'accepte répond ce dernier
là
[Applaudissements]
attention donc ça fait quatre points
pour notre esclavage
bravo attention attention
oh là là non
m
je ne garde pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très très bien ça fait donc a mon avis
oui c'est cinq points cinq mois ouais il
faut rappeler à ce moment de la partie
les règles enrico oui il a le droit de
jouer aussi wee aa je suis perturbée par
le bruit mais attention attention
[Musique]
tout le monde
piqué ma vie de ces biens si jennyfer
kung fu sûr
il a perdu la main
ça fait combien
attention et à son bien à nouveau quand
j'ai juste dit c'est bien toi qui
devrait recommencer à fumer du shit mois
attention philippe
[Musique]
ouais ouais
lefort m
ça c'est pour les dames laure tu
reconnaîtras qui vraiment aux premières
notes avait vraiment bravo bravo max
ouais attention filippi
un pas une pierre du chemin et hakim se
sont alors repliés qui apprécient la
pierre
en attendant j'en attendais dans
l'équipe par équipes donc ça fait cette
fois pour l'équipe de nico je vais
maintenant attention à partir de
maintenant chacun joue pour ça l'aude
stupéfaite
jacques alingue il a compris bien
attention on commence donc avec le banco
chacun joue pour ça lag attention aux
samoa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
banana
mais bien entendu après le banco y
allait super motivant le lasser c'est
encore plus dur que le banco alors oui
on arrivait à gagner la gagne est là
mais c'est comme ça fini tu sais bien
que moi c'est comme ça que la vie est
injuste
attention philippe vive allure
l'ostentatoire vieille coque
[Musique]
c'est l'original ad c'est l'original
réparer
oui oui
c'est un point qui est partagé entre
lamberti natacha marc cluzel et di bari
kun hadi magna s'est pas refait
exactement donc céder ou celle qui va
trouver le mot
j'ai arrêté parce qu'ils vont en faire
un cd normand alors attention
ouais
attention on ne va pas attention et bien
parce que l'amitié
maintenant je vais maintenant c'est dur
c'est la méga banque aux philippines
[Musique]
là
non
tél
park
c'est dieu allah
si tu veux rien
j'aime anglais
c'est en 15 ans
hélas non
jean la base les jeunes n'ont jamais
rien fait
non non non
a fini lauper nom qui soit beau
ce moment
bosch femme de québec cha bravo vous
êtes la seule ici mais bien avant vous
appelez comment judic angélique fait
quoi dans la vie
les chanteurs et méchante et quoi
jacques martin elle chante quoi êtes
vous chantez vous avez une chance on la
voit ici
dépêchez vous de la chance si leur génie
bozizé choisi un peu de respect pour lui
si tu es toi king ju un peu de respect
pour angélique
c'est la chance de sa vie mesdames
messieurs je n'ai pas vu naître me
connais comme si elle m'avait fait elle
a accompagné mais pas elle a soutenu mes
rêves
non merci
[Applaudissements]
hélas
ouais c
et tu vois pas
l'émission dont tout le monde parlera du
monde adfe sexe magouille et culture
générale
alors la vie avec l'embellie tanière
cal s'est démarqué man
voilà en tournée dans tout ça
voilà
l'album s'appelle haut
aulas
h l'album s'appelle ont jamais ri tout à
l'olympia
du 1er au 2 mars 2003 puis en tournée
l'album s'appelle gages
k
à l'européenne
jean pierre bourgeois profession
photographe c'est édité chez ramsay
marlène mourreau chiante et benadryl
gilbert c'est la folle avec l adversaire
michel aumont
duras à partir du 28 juin
là et dans monsieur d'antoine de caunes
avec leur liberté
storage la sortie de poussière
moi-même sifaoui met fin à ça
comment j'ai un
une cellule d'al-qaïda saison cherche
des lits
jama
jamal on la retrouve sur tf1 niché dans
les faire signer
dans l'univers de la bande dessinée
c'est lui
chez flammarion j'suis bien king et
l'album super fluide
jacno s'appelle jeu villes de chine
certains comme stendhal
des bouches c'est d'éviter ces plans
patricia petibon seul album s'appelle
airs baroques français et en septembre
2003 est-ce que les à galan
le rameau à garnier
les reporters sans frontières
achetez le livre d'edouard boubat pour
la liberté de la presse dans tous les
kiosques jusqu'au 31 janvier 2003
concert de jazz au profit d'amnesty
international le 27 janvier
on ne vendait voilà c'était tout bon
d'en bas rendez vous
je crois que je
oui
[Musique]
m
je l'aimé
[Musique]
comment
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
on
je les
à la pièce de daniel